ओके सो आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ अ लेट मी
सी
ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव राइट प्लीज लेट मी
नो एवरीबडी इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड विजिबल
एवरीबडी प्लीज लेट मी नो नमस्ते गुड
इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू
नमस्ते सो एक बार बता दीजिए सभी लोग इफ आई
एम ऑडिबल एंड विजिबल क्लियरली
एक बार जल्दी से बता दीजिए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सभी लोग बताइए। ठीक है। यस सर। विज़िबल
एंड ऑडिबल। ठीक है। चलिए बढ़िया। बढ़िया।
थोड़ा डिले हो गया। तीन चार मिनट आज डिले
हो गया। आज की जो सेशन है।
बट कोई ना हम काफी कुछ आज कवर करने वाले
हैं। काफी इंटरेस्टिंग सेशन होने वाला है।
बीच में कुछ गैप आ गई थी। आप सबों को बता
ही दिया गया था। ग्रुप्स में आप सबों को
इन्फॉर्म कर दिया गया था। एंड उस गैप के
लॉस को हम कवर करेंगे। बट यहां पे मैं आप
सभी को एक चीज बताना चाहता हूं कि एसओसी
की आपकी जो ये सीरीज है इस सीरीज में अब
हमारे पास अ जो है बहुत कम टॉपिक्स बच गए
हैं जिनको हमें खत्म करना है जिनको हमें
क्लियर करना है एंड उसके बाद आपकी जो यह
एसओसी एल1 की जो सीरीज है वो कंप्लीट हो
जाएगी एंड द एंड हो जाएगा इस सीरीज का एंड
आप जो है इस सीरीज के साथ अपनी एसओसी की
जर्नी को एसओसी एल1 की जर्नी को समाप्त
करेंगे एंड एंड उस लर्निंग एक्सपीरियंस को
आप अपने करियर के अंदर इनफ्यूज करेंगे एंड
जॉब रेडी बनके आप मार्केट के अंदर जाएंगे
एंड वहां पे ट्राई करेंगे टू गेट द जॉब्स।
हालांकि सीरीज कंप्लीट करने के बाद भी कुछ
क्लासेस आएंगी जिसमें मैं आपको बताऊंगा कि
कैसे अप्लाई करना है, क्या करना है, किस
तरीके से आपको चीजें करनी है। वो सारी
चीजें भी हम करेंगे और भी बहुत सारी चीजें
आने वाली हैं। सो फॉर एवरीथिंग जस्ट वेट
एंड वॉच द अ सीरीज। नाउ आप लोगों में से
किसी ने अभी अगर स्टार्ट करा है तो कोई
बात नहीं है। अभी स्टार्ट करा है तो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है। आप कंप्लीट कर लो। इट डज़
डजंट मैटर। आप कभी भी कंप्लीट कर लो। इससे
कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता। कभी भी आप स्टार्ट
कर सकते हैं। कभी भी आप इसको कंप्लीट कर
सकते हैं। ठीक है? आज की जो क्लास है वो
आज की जो सेशन है वो स्पेशली एसआईएम के
ऊपर मैं लेकर आया हूं। क्योंकि पूरी एसओसी
के इस जर्नी में इन दिस कंप्लीट एसओसी
जर्नी मैं मानता हूं कि बिना एसआईएम के
एसओसी का कोई एकिस्टेंस नहीं है। क्योंकि
आप सबों को पहले क्लासेस में भी मैंने
बताया हुआ है कि एसआईएम क्यों इंपॉर्टेंट
होता है इतना ज्यादा। क्यों? तो सिर्फ
एडीआर से हमारा काम नहीं चलेगा। एसआईएम का
होना क्यों इतना इंपॉर्टेंट है? एंड बिना
एसआईएम के एसओसी ऑपरेशंस जो है ना
सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन सेंटर जो है वो अ मतलब
वो एग्जीक्यूटेबल नहीं है। वो फंक्शनल
नहीं है। कैन नॉट फंक्शन ऑन इट्स ओन।
राइट? सो इट्स वेरी वेरीेंट टू अह
अंडरस्टैंड द कंसेप्ट ऑफ़ एसआईएम।
जिसका मतलब होता है सिक्योरिटी इंफॉर्मेशन
एंड इवेंट मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम। एक इसके फुल
फॉर्म में आपको पूरी डेफिनेशन भी मिल
जाएगी। सिक्योरिटी इंफॉर्मेशन जो
सिक्योरिटी रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशनेशन आपको
प्रोवाइड करता है। एंड इवेंट मैनेजमेंट
सिस्टम इवेंट्स जो होते हैं जो अकरेंसेस
होते हैं जो इंसिडेंट्स होते हैं जो
अटैक्स टाइप अटैक्स या थ्रेट्स की जो
इवेंट्स होते हैं जो व्हाटएवर इवेंट्स या
कोई लॉग है या व्हाटएवर वो सारे जो हैं
उनको मैनेज करने का उनके मैनेजमेंट का एक
सिस्टम होता है एसआईएम। ठीक है? चलिए हां
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब यहां पे हम
आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं एंड वी विल बी
स्टार्टिंग हियर। नाउ
बिफोर प्रोसीडिंग आई वुड लाइक टू इन्फॉर्म
यू ऑल कि आप सबको एक सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट काम
करना है। जब भी आप वीडियोस को देख रहे हैं
ना इन वीडियोस को तो आपको एक काम जरूर
करना है कि हमारे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स Academy
सर्च कर लीजिएगा YouTube पे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
आपको यह चैनल मिल जाएगा। यहां आके अगर
आपने सब्सक्राइब नहीं करा है तो पहले तो
सब्सक्राइब कर देना है। ठीक है? इसको
सब्सक्राइब करके ऑल वाले नोटिफिकेशन ऑन कर
दीजिएगा। नोटिफिकेशन मिलती रहेगी। लाइव
सेक्शन में जाइएगा सबसे पहले और किसी भी
एसओसी के वीडियो को उठा लीजिएगा। कोई सा
भी एसओसी की जो क्लास हुई है उसको उठा
लीजिए। इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में आप चले
जाइएगा। ठीक है? यहां पे आपको दो लिंक्स
मिलेंगे। एक WhatsApp चैनल का और एक
WhatsApp ग्रुप का। दोनों लिंक्स को ओपन
कर लीजिएगा। न्यू टैब्स में। एक WhatsApp
चैनल का लिंक होगा डिफॉन एकडमी। WhatsApp
चैनल है हमारा। इसको जाके फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट है या WhatsApp पे
भी आप चैनल्स में जाके एक्सप्लोर करके
सर्च करेंगे डिफ्रॉनिक्स तो भी आपको यह
मिल जाएगा। यह इसलिए फॉलो करना है आपको
क्योंकि हमारे साइड से डिफ्रॉनिक्स के
साइट से हर चीज कुछ भी किसी भी डोमेन का
किसी भी तरह का कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन या
न्यूज़ होती है वो सबसे पहले हम इसी चैनल
पर डालते हैं। ओवरऑल तो यह कर लीजिएगा।
दूसरा यह एक ग्रुप का लिंक होगा जो कि
एसओसी के स्पेसिफिक ग्रुप है। एंड इसको
आपको ज्वाइन करना जरूरी है क्योंकि एसओसी
के रिगार्डिंग जो भी हमारी रिसोर्सेज
नोट्स या जो भी फर्दर इनेशन होती है वो
इसी ग्रुप में आती है ओनली। तो इसको जॉइ
करना बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। ये दोनों
काम आप कर लीजिएगा। उसके अलावा ये Lindin
है। Lindin पे ये मेरी प्रोफाइल है। आप इस
पे आके मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। मुझसे
इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हैं। कुछ भी लाइक इस
प्रोफाइल पे आके आप कर सकते हैं। साथ ही
में आप Lindin पे डेफ्रोनिक्स सर्च करेंगे
तो आपको डिफ़्रॉनिक्स साइबर सिक्योरिटी का
हमारा जो कंपनी का Lindin पेज है वो भी
आपको मिल जाएगा। अब इसको भी आप जरूर फॉलो
कीजिएगा क्योंकि कंपनी रिगार्डिंग हमारी
जो भी अपडेट्स हैं आपको इस पेज पे इस
Lindin पेज पे मिल जाएगी। कंपनी के
रिगार्डिंग जहां लगभग लगभग 22,000 लोग
हमसे अभी तक जुड़े हुए हैं। आप भी जुड़
सकते हैं। इसके अलावा यह हमारा Instagram
का पेज है हमारी कंपनी डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी
हैंडल के साथ। इस पे आके आप
इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल रील कंटेंट्स के लिए इसे
आके आप फॉलो कर सकते हैं। जैसे आप देख
सकते हैं साइबर स्किल चेन के बारे में,
हिडन वनेबिलिटीज़ फाइंड करने के बारे में,
फ्री वेबिनार्स की अपडेट्स हैं यहां पे
एसओसी एल1 की जॉब क्रैकिंग के बारे में
अपडेट लाइक अ लॉट ऑफ़ थिंग्स आर देयर वो आप
इस पे आप फाइंड कर सकते हैं। यह मेरी
पर्सनल Instagram प्रोफाइल है। इफ यू वांट
यू कैन कनेक्ट विद मी ऑन दिस पर्टिकुलर
प्रोफाइल। यहां पे यह है हमारी एक्स पेज
डिफ़ॉन साइबर सिक्योरिटी के डिफरfon एकडमी
हैंडल के साथ। आप इसको फॉलो जरूर कर
लीजिएगा एक्स पे। एंड यह हमारी वेबसाइट
है। इस पे आके आप हमारी जो भी हमारी तरफ
से डिटेल्स है, जानकारी ले सकते हैं। यह
हमारा एक WhatsApp नंबर है जिस पे आप हमसे
कांटेक्ट करके किसी भी तरह की क्वेरीज,
क्वेश्चंस पूछ सकते हैं। एंड हमारे एकडमी
वाले इस मेन्यू पे जाके आप हमारी कोर्सेज
को एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। ऑफर्ड बाय
डिफ्रॉनिक्स। ये सारी चीजें तो हो गई
बातें बहुत सारी। अब हम आगे की तरफ़ चलते
हैं। जो हमारा आज का सेशन होने वाला है,
उस पे फ़ोकस करते हैं। द सेशन इज़
कंसंट्रेटेड टु एसआईएम सिक्योरिटी इनेशन
एंड इवेंट मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम। इवेंट
मैनेजमेंट से आप लोग इवेंट्स को मैनेज
करने वाला सिस्टम मत समझ लीजिएगा। इवेंट
मैनेजमेंट कोर्स, इवेंट मैनेजमेंट की जॉब
वो मत समझिएगा। दिस इज़ इवेंट्स जो इवेंट्स
आपके सिस्टम के अंदर आपके एंड पॉइंट्स के
अंदर करेंटली हो रहे हैं। वो इवेंट्स है
ये। ठीक है? अब एसआईएम का जानना इसलिए
जरूरी है क्योंकि इसके बिना मैंने जैसे कि
बोला आप कल्पना नहीं कर सकते हैं एसओसी की
या एसओसी टीम की एसओसी ऑपरेशन की। आप यू
कैन नॉट इमेजिन इनफैक्ट द एसओसी या
सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन सेंटर के किसी भी तरह
के काम को आप इमेजिन नहीं कर सकते। अब
चलिए अब यहां पे मैं आपके चैट को भी पढ़
रहा हूं। आई एम रीडिंग योर चैट्स हियर।
जस्ट लेट मी सी वंस। एक बार मैं आपके
चैट्स को यहां से देख लेता हूं। यहां से
ऑन कर लेता हूं। जस्ट अ सेकंड।
जस्ट अ सेकंड। ओके। यहां से मैं आपकी
चैट्स को
वेयर इज द चैट? वेयर द चैट? वेयर इज़ द
चैट? यस यस।
गॉट इट। हम
तो यहां पे आपकी चैट्स भी ओपन हो गई है।
एंड आई कैन सी चैट्स मिडवे। कभी-कभी मैं
चैट्स देख लेता हूं। हालांकि मैं बहुत
रेगुलर नहीं देखता जब मैं आपको पढ़ा रहा
होता हूं। बट स्टिल लेट्स अ
हैव इट राइट। चलिए
ठीक है। अब यहां पे जो एसआईएम का कांसेप्ट
है उसको मैं बहुत ही बेसिक तरीके से आपको
समझाने वाला हूं। बहुत बेसिक तरीके से
आपको बताने वाला हूं। मेरा मेन मोटिव क्या
है ना आपको एसआईएम के बारे के बारे में
बताना। ठीक है? मेरा मेन मोटिव देखो अगर
रिमेनिंग क्लासेस के बारे में अगर पूछ रहे
हैं कुछ लोग अह तो मैं रिमेनिंग क्लास
क्लासेस के बारे में आपको बताना चाहता हूं
कि हमारे इस सीरीज के अंदर अब ज्यादा
क्लासेस नहीं बची हैं। अभी कुछ डिले हो
गया बीच में गैप आ गया। अदरवाइज दो-तीन
क्लासेस और हो चुकी होती तो शायद और भी कम
हो जाती। बट हम उस डिले को कवर करेंगे।
अपकमिंग क्लासेस के अंदर में फ्रीक्वेंट
कुछ क्लासेस लेके करेंगे। अ एंड अभी मुझे
लगता है कि छह सात टॉपिक्स और बचे हैं
ओनली जिसको कवर हमें करना है। उसके बाद आप
कंप्लीट रेडी हो जाएंगे एसओसी एल1
प्रोफाइल के लिए। अब मैं आपको एक चीज
बताता हूं जो एसओसी का एल1 प्रोफाइल है वो
एक बिगिनर लेवल का प्रोफाइल होता है। ठीक
है? एकदम बेसिक बिगिनर लेवल का प्रोफाइल
होता है L1 प्रोफाइल। इससे सीनियर L2, L3
एसोसिएट इंजीनियर्स होते हैं, इंसिडेंट
रेस्पोंडर्स होते हैं। ये सब होते हैं। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] L1 का काम
बहुत ज्यादा नहीं होता है। अगर देखा जाए
फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ़ डिफेंस तो होते हैं बट
उनकी काम इतनी कॉम्प्लेक्स नहीं होती है
जितनी L2 L3 की होती है। तो आपके पास जो
लिमिटेड टॉपिक्स होते हैं जिनको आपको
जानना है टू क्रैक द जॉब ऑफ एसओसी एल1। तो
एक एंट्री पॉइंट चाहिए आपको ब्लू टीमिंग
में एंटर होने के लिए। क्योंकि आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी डोमेन में रेड टीमिंग या ब्लू
टीमिंग दो तरीके से एंटर कर सकते हैं। ठीक
है? बहुत लोग बोलते हैं ऑरेंज टीम, पर्पल
टीम ये सब बेकार की चीजें हैं। बकवास
चीजें हैं। इनको प्लीज साइड कर दीजिए।
प्लीज डोंट फोकस ऑन दैट। पर्पल टीम, ऑरेंज
टीम ये सब हटाइए। पहले रेड टीम एंड ब्लू
टीम के तौर पे ही आप एंट्री लेते हैं।
दैट्स इट। अब रेड टीमिंग की ऑलरेडी जो है
रेड टीमिंग के रिगार्डिंग हमारी
डब्ल्यूएपीटी वेब एप्लीकेशन पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग की यानी बग बाउंटी मैं उसको बग
बाउंट की तरह लेकर आया था। हालांकि पेन
टेस्टिंग की तरह नहीं बग बाउंट की तरह
लेकर आया था। तो उसकी ऑलरेडी प्लेलिस्ट
बनी है। उसमें ऑलरेडी क्लासेस हो रखी है।
उसको देख के आप रेड टीमिंग वाली पाथ को
चूज़ कर सकते हैं। ब्लू टीमिंग में हमारे
पास कोई भी ट्रेनिंग नहीं थी। तो हमने यह
एसओसी का एल1 प्रोफाइल का ट्रेनिंग लेकर
हम आए और आपको कंप्लीट करा रहे हैं। तो एक
बहुत ही इजी वे होता है टू एंटर इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी विद एसओसी जॉब। तो यह जैसे ही
यह हमारी कुछ छह सात टॉपिक और आठ टॉपिक और
कंप्लीट हो जाएंगी यू विल बी रेडी फॉर दैट
एंड आप जाके इंटरव्यूज जो हैं वो दे सकते
हैं। ठीक है? उसके बाद यहां पे आई एम आई
एम गुड अलबिरोनी। उसके बाद उसके बाद अब
यहां पे मेरा यहां पे मेन कुछ अब मेन-मेन
टॉपिक्स स्टार्ट हो चुके हैं। जैसे कि
आपका इडीआर टॉपिक था एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन
वाला जो टॉपिक था वो काफी इंपॉर्टेंट था।
उस पे आपने देखा 3 घंटे क्लासेस क्लास हुई
थी आपकी। एसआईएम एक और बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट
टॉपिक है। अब एसआईएम में हम स्प्लक को
लेकर चल सकते हैं। तो वो भी एक काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक होगा। राइट? तो ये सारे
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक्स को हम लेकर चलने वाले
हैं। अब यहां पे
मैं आपको एसआईएम के बारे में बताऊंगा। मैं
बहुत नॉर्मल और ऐसे तरीके से बताऊंगा
जिससे आपको एसआईएम समझ में आ जाए। ज्यादा
कचरा नहीं करना है। ठीक है ना? ज्यादा
कचरा नहीं समझना है। ज्यादा कॉम्प्लेक्स
नहीं करना है। हमें जानना है एसआईएम क्या
होता है? देखो, एसआईएम इज़ द
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सिंगल कोर
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ऑफ अ मॉडर्न एसओसी।
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ऑफ़ एसओसी। ऐसा क्यों कहा
जा रहा है? क्योंकि आपके पास अगर लैपटॉप
है, पीसी है और उसमें अगर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
नहीं है तो वो एक डब्बा है। राइट? आपने
लैपटॉप खरीद लिया। अगर उसमें ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम आप नहीं डालते हो और इंस्टॉल नहीं
करते हो तो वो एक डब्बा है। यू कैन नॉट
यूज़ योर लैपटॉप फॉर एनी काइंड ऑफ़ टास्क।
उसी तरीके से एसओसी एनवायरमेंट के लिए एक
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की तरह है। आपका एसआईएम।
इट [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इज़ अ
मैसिव डेटा लेक। यह एक डेटा का तालाब है।
डिज़ फॉर रियल टाइम स्ट्रीमिंग एनालिटिक्स।
लॉन्ग टर्म सिक्योरिटी रिटेंशन एंड
फॉरेंसिक कंप्लायंसेस। इसको इसी तरीके से
डिजाइन किया गया है कि यह रियल टाइम में
डाटा को मॉनिटर करें। सिक्योरिटी का ध्यान
रखें एंड जो भी इन्वेस्टिगेशन की चीजों के
लिए जो भी चीजें इन्वेस्टिगेशन के लिए
रिक्वायरमेंट है उसके अकॉर्डिंग ये काम
करें। कंप्लायंस जो है उसका भी ध्यान
रखें। फॉरेंसिक्स कंप्लायंस ये सारी चीजें
अभी मैं आपको बहुत इजी तरीके में बताऊंगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इन अ सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन सेंटर एसओसी द
एसआईएम सिक्योरिटी इनेशन एंड इन्वेंट
मैनेजर सिस्टम इज द ब्रेन ये इसका ब्रेन
है ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है ब्रेन है व्हाटएवर
यू कैन से इफ एन ईडीआर गिव्स यू स इफ इफ
एन ईडीआर गिव्स यू साइट इंटू एंड पॉइंट्स
द एसआईएम गिव्स यू साइट इंटू द एंटायर
एंटप्राइज
मजिंग लॉग्स फ्रॉम नेटवर्क्स क्लाउड्स
फायर वाल्स एप्लीकेशनेशंस इंटू वन सिंगल
पेन ऑफ़ क्लास। सिंपल। अब मैं आपको एसआईएम
का मतलब समझाता हूं।
देखो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इंटरनेट पे जितने भी यानी एक नेटवर्क
इंटरनेट छोड़ो एक नेटवर्क के अंदर जितने
भी डिवाइसेस होते हैं जितने भी डिवाइसेस
हैं वो सब किसी ना किसी तरह के लॉग्स को
जनरेट करते हैं। या जो भी आप एक्टिविटी
करते हो उससे एक लॉग जनरेट होती है। आपने
कोई फाइल डाउनलोड की वहां भी लॉक जनरेट
होती है। आपने किसी को ईमेल भेजा वहां भी
लॉक डाउन लॉग जनरेट होती है। आपने किसी से
वीडियो कॉल पे बात की वहां भी लॉक जनरेट
होती है। आपने कोई फाइल ओपन की वहां भी
लॉक जनरेट होती है। आपने कोई फोल्डर में
फाइल को कॉपी किया वहां भी लॉक जनरेट होती
है। आपने कोई फाइल डिलीट की वहां भी लॉक
जनरेट होती है। इवन आप एक हैकर हैं और
आपने एक बैकडोर एंट्री बना ली है और अब आप
पोस्ट एक्सप्लॉयटेशन के बाद अपने ट्रैक्स
को कवर करने के लिए इवेंट्स को यानी लॉग्स
को ही डिलीट कर रहे हैं। वहां भी लॉग
जनरेट होती है। तो हर जगह पे एक लॉग जनरेट
जनरेशन का काम होता है। लॉग्स जनरेट होते
हैं। अब यही जो अलग-अलग डिवाइसेस से लॉग्स
जनरेट होते हैं उन सबको एक जगह पे कलेक्ट
करके एक जगह पे प्रोसेस करके और अलर्ट शो
करना थ्रेट्स के बारे में अलर्ट करना
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट्स को या एसोसिएट
एनालिस्ट्स को यह काम है आपके एसआईएम का।
ठीक है?
सर प्लीज स्पीक इन इंग्लिश ऑलवेज वी कांट
अंडरस्टैंड हिंदी। यहां पे हिंदी वाले ही
बात करते हैं और हिंदी वाले ही रहेंगे।
इंग्लिश में हम क्लासेस नहीं लेते हैं
ब्रदर। सो एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी फॉर दैट। यू
शुड मूव टू सम इंग्लिश चैनल्स। हमारा
कंटेंट जो लैंग्वेज मीडियम है वो हिंदी ही
होता है। ठीक है? सो आप हिंदी या तो सीख
लीजिए या तो आप इंग्लिश किसी इंग्लिश
कंटेंट क्रिएटर के अ वीडियोस पे मूव कर
जाइए। दैट वुड बी मच बेटर। तो यहां सारे
लॉग्स को एक जगह पर कलेक्ट करके और उस पे
प्रोसेसिंग का काम करना यह एसआईएम का काम
होता है। दिस इज द वर्क ऑफ एसआईएम
सिक्योरिटी इनफेशन एंड मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम।
बस अभी तक आपको एसआईएम को लेके जितनी भी
डाउट्स थी, क्वेरीज थी, समझ नहीं आता था,
एक क्वेश्चन एक आंसर में आपको आई थिंक समझ
आ जाना चाहिए अब जाके। आई होप कि आप सब ने
एसआईएम का कांसेप्ट समझ लिया है। एसआईएम
का कांसेप्ट यहीं पर समाप्त होता है।
लेकिन मैं आपको और एक्सटेंडेड इसके
वर्किंग, प्रोसेससेस, ऑपरेशन सब बताऊंगा।
इसलिए ये क्लास लेकर आया। अदरवाइज ओनली
एसआईएम के बारे में बताना था। तो यहीं पे
खत्म हो जाती है आपकी एसआईएम। कि जितने भी
लॉग्स हैं उन सबको को-रिलेट करना, उन सबको
एक फॉर्मेट में लेकर आना और उस पे फर्दर
प्रोसेसिंग और एनालिसिस करके और अलर्ट को
थ्रो करना यह एसआईएम का काम है। दैट्स इट।
अब वह लॉग्स नेटवर्क से, क्लाउड से,
फायरवल से, एप्लीकेशन से कहीं से भी आ
सकते हैं। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] डड
यू गेट एवरीवन
गेट दिस पर्टिकुलर पॉइंट?
एवरीवन गॉट दिस पर्टिकुलर पॉइंट? सॉरी
एवरीवन गॉट दिस पर्टिकुलर पॉइंट? प्लीज
लेट मी नो। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सभी लोग बताइए।
प्लीज रिप्लाई एवरीवन। आई एम एक्सपेक्टिंग
रिस्पांस फ्रॉम मोस्ट ऑफ यू।
[खांसने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है। चलिए सो
ओके काफी लोगों ने रिप्लाई फाइनली किया
है। अच्छी बात है।
ठीक है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
ठीक है। चलिए
ओके वेरी गुड अगर आप देखो आपको समझ में
आना चाहिए यही मेन मोटिव है अगर आपको समझ
में आ रहा है दैट्स इट मोटिव इज़ फुलफिल्ड
अब यहां पे आते हैं एसओसी के अंदर एसआईएम
डैशबोर्ड का एक ओवरव्यू देखते हैं ठीक है
ये एक ओवरव्यू है ठीक है
सर मुझे एसओसी
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एल1 का इंटर्नशिप लगा है थैंक यू सर ओके
ग्रेट अ
सुशामन दास कांग्रेचुलेशंस ऑन गेटिंग द
इंटर्नशिप आई एम गुड अयान अयान मोहम्मद
थैंक यू फॉर आस्किंग
अब यहां पे एसआईएम
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] डैशबोर्ड को एक
बार देखते हैं कुछ इस तरीके का एसआईएम का
एक डैशबोर्ड होता है लाइक यहां पे हम जो
है एक स्प्लंक टाइप डैशबोर्ड की बात कर
रहे हैं यहां पे जैसे कोई भी एसआईएम होती
है उनका कुछ इसी तरीके अब देखो एसआईएम जो
टूल्स होते हैं बहुत सारे आते हैं लाइक
स्प्लंक है सेंट एंटिनल वन है। राइट? अ
देयर आर लॉट ऑफ़ इंट्रा आईडी करके अब जैसे
Microsoft के आते हैं और बहुत सारे। तो
देयर आर लॉट ऑफ़ टूल्स दैट कम्स
एसआईएम के सॉलशंस बहुत सारे हैं। जिसमें
बहुत ज्यादा पॉपुलर जो है वो आपका स्प्लंक
और सेंटिनल वन है। काफी ज्यादा पॉपुलर है।
राइट? सो यहां पे हम इनके डैशबोर्ड को अगर
देखें तो कुछ इस तरीके का डैशबोर्ड होता
है एसआईएम का आपका जहां पे एक जो कॉलन है
आपका एक जो आपका यहां पे एरिया है उसमें
थ्रेट लैंडस्केप का ओवरव्यू होता है।
थ्रेट्स का ओवरव्यू होता है। दूसरे जो
कॉलम आपका जो एरिया है उसमें इंसिडेंट
क्यू एंड इन्वेस्टिगेशन से रिलेटेड इनेशन
होती है। तीसरा जो है उसमें डेटा सोर्सेज
इन्वेस्टिगेशन हेल्थ से रिलेटेड होती है।
चौथा जो है एंटिटी बिहेवियर एंड हंटिंग से
रिलेटेड होता है। तो आप देख सकते हैं जैसे
कि इस तरीके से यहां पे दिखता है कि
ग्लोबल अलर्ट सीवियरिटी आपको दिख रहा है
यहां पे। जैसे क्रिटिकल कितने अलर्ट्स हैं
जो है क्रिटिकल है। कितने हाई में है, हाई
सीवियरिटी के हैं, कितने मीडियम सीवियरिटी
के हैं, कितने लो सीवियरिटी के हैं? ये
सारे दिख रहे हैं। टॉप अटैक वेक्टर्स आपको
दिखते हैं कि सबसे ज्यादा अटैक्स किस टाइप
के हो रहे हैं। ठीक है? सबसे ज्यादा
अटैक्स किस टाइप के हो रहे हैं? फिशिंग के
अटैक सबसे ज्यादा जैसे यहां पे दिख रहा
होगा आपको फिशिंग के सबसे ज्यादा हो रहे
हैं। मैलवेयर अटैक्स उसके बाद आपके हो रहे
हैं। क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग से रिलेटेड
अटैक्स हो रहे हैं। डीडीओएस काफी ज्यादा
हो रहे हैं। और यहां पे अलर्ट का वॉल्यूम
आपको दिखेगा कि लास्ट 24 घंटे या जो भी
टाइम फ्रेम आप सेलेक्ट करेंगे उसमें कितनी
ज्यादा जो है ना वो अलर्ट्स आपको थ्रो हुई
है। तो आप देख सकते हैं एक टाइम पे 12:00
बजे के आसपास यहां पे सबसे ज्यादा अलर्ट
थ्रो हुए हैं। फिर यहां पे 7:00 बजे के
आसपास काफी ज्यादा अलर्ट्स जो है वो थ्रो
हुए हैं। तो एक पर्टिकुलर टाइम में ये पता
चलता है इससे कि किस पर्टिकुलर टाइम में
सबसे ज्यादा अलर्ट्स जो हैं वो थ्रो हो
रहे हैं। एंड उन टाइम्स में हो सकता है जो
आपके सिस्टम है उनको ज्यादा के ज्यादा
टारगेट किए जा रहे हैं। ठीक है? उसी तरीके
से इंसिडेंट क्यू एंड इन्वेस्टिगेशन की
अगर हम बात करें तो यहां पे भी आपको दिख
जाएगा कि प्रायोरिटी इंसिडेंट्स आपको
दिखेंगे। लाइक आईडी होती है सबकी
सीवियरिटी आपको यहां पे दिखेगा एंड उसमें
आपको प्रायोरिटी दिखेंगी। ठीक है? तो
इसमें आपको दिखेगा कि कौन सा यूजर या
होस्ट है जो अफेक्टेड है। स्टेटस इसका
क्या है? लाइक जो आप एक एसोसिएट एल1 की
तरह आप जब काम कर रहे होंगे तो आपने उसको
ट्रैग किया है कि उसको रॉल्व कर दिया है
कि इन प्रोग्रेस चल रहा है। क्या है और
किस पर्टिकुलर एल1 या जो एसओसी एल वन
एनालिस्ट है किसको वो टैग्ड मतलब किसने
अपने आप को टैग किया साइन किया है उनका
नाम यहां पे दिखता है। ठीक है? उसके
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] बाद यहां पे
मेन टाइम टू एकनॉलेज दिखता है आपको। को
मीन टाइम टू एकनॉलेज के बारे में अगर आपको
नहीं पता तो पिछले क्लासेस में ऑलरेडी
इनके ऊपर में एमटीटीए और एमटीटीआर के ऊपर
पूरी डिटेल में डिस्कशन करी हुई है मैंने।
इनके बारे में मैंने आपको बताया हुआ है।
अब आपसे यही चीज मैं आपको पहले भी बोलता आ
रहा था। अभी फिर से बोलूंगा कि आप में से
कई लोग प्रैक्टिकल के लिए बहुत ज्यादा बोल
रहे थे कि सर प्रैक्टिकल कब आएगा?
प्रैक्टिकल कब आएगा? अभी हमने स्टार्टअप
कर दिया है। लैब्स वगैरह अब करेंगे। इनका
प्रैक्टिकल मतलब लैब्स और थ्यरी दोनों को
मिला के ही प्रैक्टिकल। क्योंकि एस जब आप
एसओसी की बात करते हैं तो एसओसी मोस्टली
इज़ थ्यरी एंड द लैब्स द प्रैक्टिकल। तो उस
चीज को समझने के लिए मैंने आपको पहले ही
बोला था कि आपको थ्यरी जो कांसेप्ट्स हैं
वो समझ में आना बहुत जरूरी है। क्योंकि
अगर आपको ये एमटीटी एमटीटीआर नहीं पता और
कंपनी में जाएंगे आप आपका सिलेक्शन होगा।
आप जब जॉब के पहले दिन जाएंगे और आपको यह
दिखने को मिल जाएगा तो आपको तो समझ में
नहीं आएगा यह क्या है। आप कैसे परफॉर्म
करेंगे? सिंपल सी बात है। बिना कांसेप्ट
और थ्योरी का कोई भी नॉलेज प्रॉपर नॉलेज
नहीं होता है। सिंपल एज एज सून एज मतलब एज
इट इज़ जैसा मैं बोल रहा हूं आपको कि बिना
कांसेप्ट के कुछ भी पॉसिबल नहीं है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] बिना
कांसेप्ट का कोई प्रैक्टिकल नहीं होता है।
पहले कोई भी अगर कोई प्रैक्टिकल चीज भी
होती है ना कभी जैसे साइंटिस्ट्स होते हैं
जो होते हैं। कोई भी चीज को प्रैक्टिकली
परफॉर्म करने से पहले उसका एक थ्यरिटिकल
टेस्ट थ्यरिटिकल पार्ट बनाया जाता है। एक
थ्यरेटिकल एक डेमोंस्ट्रेशन होती है कि ये
चीज एक्चुअली ऑन पेपर पॉसिबल है कि नहीं
है। अगर पॉसिबल है तो फिर उसका प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन होता है। बिना उससे कुछ भी
नहीं होता। ठीक है?
हां। और इंटरव्यू में आपसे थ्योरी ही पूछा
जाता है। इंटरव्यू में आपसे थ्योरेटिकल
नॉलेज आपकी ली जाती है। इंटरव्यू में
थोड़ी ना आपको
स्प्लंक या कोई भी एसआईए हम सॉल्यूशन का
वो खोल के आपको दे देंगे कि भाई इस पे
प्रैक्टिकल परफॉर्म करो। ऐसा नहीं होता
है। नाउ द नेक्स्ट इज़ द डेटा सोर्सेज एंड
इंजेशन हेल्थ। डेटा सोर्सेज मतलब कि
कहां-कहां से डेटा जैसे क्लाउड से, फायरवल
से, एंड पॉइंट से, आइडेंटिटी या यूजर के
तरफ से डेटा जो है वो सब डेटा जो है वो जा
रही हैं लॉग्स। डेटा का मतलब यहां पे
लॉग्स की बात कर रहा हूं। जब भी एसओसी के
कंटेस्टक्स्ट में हम बात करेंगे वी विल से
देम लॉग्स। तो यहां इन सब जगहों से लॉग्स
कलेक्ट हो रही हैं। एक जगह पे जा रही है
जहां पे वो फिर पार्सिंग होता है और
कोरिलेशन होता है। उन जहां पे उनका पासिंग
एंड कोरिलेशन होता है। देन वहां पे
इंडेक्सिंग टियर होती है। इंडेक्स किया
जाता है उनको एंड फिर जाके जो है आगे की
प्रोसेससेस उसमें होती है एनालिसिस वगैरह
का। ये सब होता है। एंड देन लास्ट में
एंटिटी बिहेवियर हंटिंग होता है जिसमें
जिओआईपी एनोमलीज़ जहां पे एक ग्राफ के थ्रू
एक अच्छी [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] खासी
ग्राफ मतलब होती है। उसके थ्रू अच्छा खासा
एक डेमोंस्ट्रेशन करके मतलब समझाया जाता
है। बताया जाता है कि भैया एग्जैक्टली
कहां-कहां पे क्या-क्या चीजें एग्जैक्टली
ज्यादा थ्रेट्स हैं, ज्यादा अटैक्स हो रहे
हैं। किस तरीके से हो रही है। यहां पे आप
देखोगे टॉप एट रिस्क एंटिटीज़ आपको दिखेगा।
यूज़र्स में वीपी फाइनेंस डेव डेवलपर लीड
डेवलपर लीड ये सबसे ज्यादा हाई रिस्क पे
हैं जो फाइनेंस वाले हैं डेवलपर वाले हैं
एंड होस्ट नेम आपको दिखेंगे हाई रिस्क है
लो रिस्क है ये सब चीजें आपको दिखेंगी वो
सारी और ग्राफ के थ्रू आपको विजुअलाइज़
किया जाएगा। ठीक है? तो कुछ इसी तरीके का
आपको डेमोंस्ट्रेशन जो होता है वो आपको
देखने को मिलेगा। कुछ इस तरह का जो है
आपको डैशबोर्ड जो है वो देखने का देखने को
मिलेगा। राइट? देखो अब एसओसी की जब बात
करते हैं जब एसओसी के टूल्स की बात करते
हैं इन इस इन इस इन इस इन इस इन इस इन इस
इन इस इन इस इन इस इन इस इन इस इन इस इन
इस इन इस इन इस इन इस इन इस इन इस इन इस
इन इस इन तरह के टूल की तो आपको लैब्स के
थ्रू ही डेमो के थ्रू ही समझना पड़ेगा
क्योंकि इनके जो टूल्स हैं वो एंटरप्राइज
लेवल के अ प्राइसिंग पे आते हैं। आप
एफोर्ड नहीं कर सकते। कोई भी बाय नहीं कर
सकता नॉर्मली क्योंकि अब हमारी भी जैसे
कंपनी है तो हमारी कंपनी का
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर इतना बड़ा अगर होता कि हम
एससी एसओसी की टीम हायर करने होते तो
हमारे पास तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है ये टूल
होती। बट ये जो एसओसी ऑपरेशंस होते हैं वो
बड़ी कंपनीज़ के लिए बहुत बड़ी जिनके
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है वहां पर रिक्वायर्ड
है। छोटी या मिड लेवल कंपनीज़ के लिए एसओसी
ऑपरेशंस या एसओसी टीम की रिक्वायरमेंट
नहीं होती है। इस वजह से ये जो टूल्स है
काफी महंगे मिलते हैं। तो आपको ये जो डेमो
है डेमो के थ्रू आपको समझना है और जब आप
उस कंपनी में जाएंगे काम करने तो आपको हर
कुछ सामने दिखेगा ना जो चीज़ आपने सीखी है
जो चीज़ आपने समझी है तो आपको बहुत मजा आने
वाला है। आपको बहुत लिटरली बहुत अच्छा
लगेगा जब आपको सामने दिखेगा और आप उस पे
प्रैक्टिस आप उस पे परफॉर्म करोगे तो जब
नॉलेज ऑलरेडी होगी। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए अब आगे की तरफ चलते हैं। अब हम इसका
जो एसआईएम है इसका एक आर्किटेक्चरल
ब्लूप्रिंट समझते हैं। यानी कि द इंजेशन
एंड प्रोसेसिंग पाइपलाइन। ये एग्जजेक्टली
कैसे डेटा को प्रोसेस कैसे जो लॉग होती है
जो लॉग्स देखो अब यहां पे मैं आपको क्या
समझाने जा रहा हूं पूरे प्रोसेस के थ्रू
कि किस तरीके से एसआईएम जो होती है अब
क्या होता है कि लॉग्स लॉग्स जनरेट हो रही
हैं सारे एंड पॉइंट्स से मतलब कि फायर वॉल
से हो गया मशीनंस कंप्यूटर से हो गया
लैपटॉप से हो गया या किसी डिवाइस से हो गई
नेटवर्क डिवाइस से हो गई राइट कहीं से भी
हो रही है वहां से जो लॉक जनरेट हो रही है
और लॉक जनरेट होने के बाद एसआईएम के पास आ
रही है और एसआईएम उस लॉग को एनालिसिस करने
के बाद से एक अलर्ट देता है। जिस अलर्ट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] को एसओसी एल1
आपके जैसे एसओसी जो एल1 होंगे वो अलर्ट को
देखते हैं कि भैया यहां से अलर्ट आया है।
उसके बाद उस अलर्ट को वो अपने आप को असाइन
करते हैं और फिर फ़दर प्रोसेसिंग करते हैं।
देखते हैं कि यह ट्रू पॉजिटिव है कि फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव है। अगर फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है तो वहां
पे अपना रीज़ डिस्क्रिप्शन डाल के उसको एंड
कर देते हैं। बंद कर देते हैं। और अगर
ट्रू पॉजिटिव है तो देखते हैं। फिर आगे की
तरफ उसको बढ़ाते हैं वह फ़ॉरवर्ड मतलब एस-
एस्केलेट करते हैं एल उम एल टू एल थ्री के
लिए। तो मैं यहां पे यह जो प्रोसेस अब
पूरा बताने वाला हूं यह लॉग जनरेट होने से
लेकर और एस ओ और एसआईएम के तरफ से जो आपके
अलर्ट थ्रो होती है वहां तक के बीच का
प्रोसेस मैं आपको समझाने वाला हूं। उस
पूरे मतलब लॉक जनरेट होने से ले और अलर्ट
थ्रो होने तक के बीच में जो जो प्रोसेससेस
होती हैं ना वो बहुत लंबी प्रोसेस होती है
क्योंकि ये मशीन है क्योंकि एक कंप्यूटर
है तो तुरंत आपको तुरंत फ्रैक्शन ऑफ़ सेकंड
में आपको सामने दिखने लगता है सारी चीजें
लेकिन उसके बीच बहुत सारी चीजें एक्चुअली
में होती है। ठीक है? जैसे आपने थ्री वे
हैंडशक वगैरह पढ़ा होगा कि आपने देखा होगा
थ्री हैंडसेक में आपने यह भी पढ़ा होगा ना
कि जैसे अब आप ब्राउज़र में जाके
Facebook.com खोलते हो तो आप जैसे
facebook.com डालो और एंटर किया Facebook
का लॉगिन पेज आ जाता है या उसका होम पेज आ
जाता है। बट उसके बीच में बहुत बड़ी एक
प्रोसेस चल रही होती है। क्लाइंट सर्वर के
बीच बातें हो रही होती हैं। एक्सचेंज हो
रहा एक्सचेंज ऑफ़ डेटा हो रहा होता है।
सिंक एसी के इन सब चीजों पे जो है ये सब
चीजें हो रही होती हैं। एचटीटीपी मेथड्स
काम कर रहे होते हैं। देयर आर लॉट ऑफ़
थिंग्स दैट इज़ बीइंग हैपनिंग इन बिटवीन
दैट प्रोसेस। तो वही चीज हम यहां पे जानने
वाले हैं। ठीक है? सो आर यू रेडी फॉर द
दिस फॉर द दिस पर्टिकुलर नॉलेज जो आपको
मैं अभी देने वाला हूं कि बीच में
क्या-क्या हो रहा है। सभी लोग रेडी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
देखो ईडीआर और ईडीआर और एसआईएम में बहुत
अंतर है। मैंने पहले भी बता दिया था। मैं
इसीलिए बोलता हूं कि प्लीज प्लीज वॉच
एव्री सेशन एवरीवन। ईडीआर इज अ डिफरेंट
थिंग। एडीआर अलग चीज है।
और एसआईएम के अंदर ही ईडीआर को इंटीग्रेट
कर दिया जाता है। क्योंकि ईडीआर के भी
लॉग्स जो होते हैं वो बाकी लॉक्स के साथ
कंबाइंड हो के एक जगह पे एक सेंट्रलाइज्ड
सिस्टम पे जाते हैं और वहां से फिर
प्रोसेसिंग होता है। ठीक है? अब मैं आपको
बताता हूं वो भी आ जाएगा अभी बाद में।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? वो भी कवर हो जाएगा आपका क्वेश्चन
भी। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] देखो अब
इसका आर्किटेक्ट समझते हैं। ठीक है?
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
अ एसआईएम इज एसेंशियली अ जॉइंट मशीन
एक जॉइंट मशीन है दैट इंजेस्ट्स
अनस्ट्रक्चरर्ड और सेमीस्ट्रक्चर डेटा।
इंजेस्ट का मतलब है इंसर्ट कर देना।
इंजेस्ट अगर आप देख रहे हैं कहीं पे या
इंजेशन तो मतलब इंसर्ट या अंदर मतलब कि
हां वहां तक पहुंचा देना। इसका मतलब आप
यही समझ लो। ठीक है? दैट इंजिस्ट
अनस्ट्रक्चरर्ड और सेमीस्ट्रक्चरर्ड डेटा
नॉर्मलाइजेस इट ऑन द फ्लाइस। फिर
नॉर्मलाइज उसको करते हैं। सारे डेटा को एक
जगह घुसाते हैं। एक जगह रखते हैं। फिर
नॉर्मलाइज करते हैं उसको एंड ऑप्टिमाइज
इट। फॉर फॉर्मेट वगैरह सब सेम करते हैं।
फॉर अल्ट्राफास्ट टेक्स्ट सर्च। स्प्लंक
अचीव दिस वाया डिफरेंट डिस्टिंक्ट
आर्किटेक्चरल स्टेजेस। अब स्प्लंक जो है
इसको ही अलग-अलग स्टेजेस में परफॉर्म करता
है। ठीक है? तो उस एसआईएम का सिंपल सा काम
होता है कि एक अनस्ट्रक्चरर्ड या सेमी
स्ट्रक्चर डेटा को लाना, कलेक्ट करना,
उनको नॉर्मलाइज करना, उनको ऑप्टिमाइज करना
सर्च के लिए ये तीन चीज करती है। ठीक है?
डेटा को इंजेस्ट करना, उनको नॉर्मलाइज
करना और उनको ऑप्टिमाइज करना। बस बात
खत्म। इसी में जो एक स्प्लंक है जो कि एक
एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन है। एसआईएम टूल है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? कोई बात नहीं। ये जो स्प्लंक है
ये इसको तीन स्टेजेस में या डिफरेंट
स्टेजेस में परफॉर्म करता है। तो मैं उन
स्टेजेस की बात आपको बताने वाला हूं। पहले
स्टेज वन पे आते हैं। स्टेज ए पे कलेक्शन
द एज फॉरवर्ड।
ठीक है? पहले [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कलेक्शन की बात करते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब देखो,
लॉक्स ओरिजनेट एट द एज ऑफ द नेटवर्क। एज
ऑफ द नेटवर्क पर लॉग जनरेट होते हैं। ठीक
है? एंड पॉइंट्स पे एंड पॉइंट्स पर यहां
पर कहने की बात है एंड पॉइंट्स पर लॉग
जनरेट्स होते हैं। स्प्लंक यूजज़ यूनिवर्सल
फॉरवर्ड। इसको हम यूएफएस बोलते हैं।
यूएफएस। ठीक है? यूएफ बोल दो, यूएफएस बोल
दो, फॉरवर्ड्स होते हैं। तो एस लग गया
वहां पे। स्प्लंक जो है यहां पे यूनिवर्सल
फॉरवर्ड्स को यूज़ करता है। हाइली
ऑप्टिमाइज्ड जो कि क्या होते हैं? हली
ऑप्टिमाइज C++ बाइनरीज़ जो यूनिवर्सल
फॉरवर्ड होते हैं, यह एक हाईली ऑप्टिमाइज
C++ बाइनरीज़ होते हैं। दैट रन विद ऑलमोस्ट
ज़ीरो CPU ओवरहेड ऑन एंड पॉइंट्स जिसको रन
करने के लिए किसी तरह का कंप्यूटेशनल पावर
की रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं होता। मतलब सीपीयू
का कुछ खास यूज़ ये नहीं करते हैं। कोई भी
सीपीयू या सर्वर एंड डोमेन कंट्रोलर मतलब
ऑन एंड मतलब किसी भी तरह का लाइक वो चाहे
एंड पॉइंट्स पे चल रहे हो, सर्वर्स पे चल
रहे हो, डोमेन कंट्रोलर्स पे चल रहे हो,
सीपीयू का ज्यादा यूज़ नहीं करते हैं। ठीक
है? ये यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्ड होते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब इसमें क्या
मैकेनिज्म है? उसको समझते हैं। ठीक है? द
मैकेनिज़्म। द यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर्स यूसेस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन टेंपल्लेट्स। ये यूनिवर्सल
फॉरवर्ड ध्यान से सुनिएगा सभी लोग। देखिए
अभी हम उस स्टेज पे हैं। मैं आपको फिर से
एक बार बताना चाहता हूं। अभी हम एसओसी के
इन क्लासेस के उन स्टेज पे हैं। जहां अगर
आप ध्यान नहीं देंगे तो आपको समझ नहीं
आएगा। और अगर आपका थ्यरी कांसेप्ट क्लियर
है तो ही आपको समझ में आएगा। तभी मैं
बार-बार जब क्लासेस लेता था तो लोगों को
बोलता था सबको कि प्लीज फोकस ऑन द
कांसेप्ट्स। बहुत लोग फोकस करते थे। वो आज
भी यहां पे हैं और फोकस कर रहे हैं और
उनको समझ में भी आ रहा होगा। कई लोग शायद
फोकस नहीं करते होंगे तो शायद ऊपर से चला
जाए। तो फोकस कीजिए आज भी हो सकता है अभी
आपको समझ में आ जाए। तो यूनिवर्सल
फॉरवर्डस जो होते थे जो होते हैं जिसको
स्प्लंक यूज़ करता है। ठीक है?
यूज कॉन्फ़िगरेशन टेंपल्लेट्स प्राइमरली
इनपुट्स डॉट कॉफ एक मतलब एक इनपुट्स डॉट
कॉन्फ करके फाइल है। वहां से यह एक
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन टेंपलेट को यूज़ करता है टू
मॉनिटर स्पेसिफिक डायरेक्टरीज़। किस चीज़ के
लिए यूज़ करता है ये टेंपलेट्स का?
स्पेसिफिक डायरेक्टरीज़ को मॉनिटर करने के
लिए। और इवेंट चैनल्स या इवेंट चैनल्स को
जैसे विन इवेंट Windows इवेंट लॉग हो गया
डॉट स्लश सिक्योरिटी ये एक इवेंट चैनल्स
होते हैं जहां पे लॉग्स के चैनल्स होते
हैं वो उनको मैनेज करने के लिए इट रीड्स द
लॉग लाइंस रैप्स इट इन अ लाइट वेट
फ्रेमिंग प्रोटोकॉल एंड स्ट्रीम शंट्स इट
ओवर टीसीp पोर्ट 997
इसका काम क्या है? यह लॉग्स के लाइंस को
पढ़ता है। इसको एक लाइट वेट प्रोटोकॉल के
अंदर बांध के रखता है। छोटे से प्रोटोकॉल
के अंदर इसको फ्यूज करता है। एंड स्ट्रीम
शंट्स इट ओवर और इसको किसके एंड कहां से
और इसको ट्रांसफर किससे और स्ट्रीम किसके
थ्रू करता है? एक टीसीबी पोर्ट होती है
597 इस पोर्ट पे इसको स्ट्रीम करता है।
यानी कि इसको आगे फॉरवर्ड करता है। ठीक
है? तो ये इस मतलब ट्रांसफर करता है। यू
कैन से इस तरीके से ये हमारा यूनिवर्सल
फॉरवर्डर जो है वो काम
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] करता है। अब अगर
आपसे कोई इवेंट अ मान लो इंटरव्यू में
आपसे पूछ सकता है। ठीक है? कि यूनिवर्सल
फॉरवर्डर जो है वो नॉर्मली स्ट्रीम शंट्स
या स्ट्रीमिंग जो है डेटा की जो लॉग्स की
है लाइन वो किस पोर्ट पे करता है? तो आपको
वहां जवाब देना पड़ेगा कि यह पोर्ट टीसीपी
पोर्ट नंबर 597 पे करता है या आपसे
एमसीक्यू पूछा जा सकता है। वहां पे आप यह
ऑप्शन सेलेक्ट कर सकते हैं। राइट? तो दीज़
आर काइंड ऑफ इंटरव्यू क्वेश्चंस जो आपके
पास आ सकती है आपसे। तो इस तरीके से ये
मैकेनिज्म है यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डस का। पहला
दूसरा।
अब यहां पे आते हैं
स्टेज बी पे।
हमने स्टेज वन देख लिया यहां पर कलेक्शन
का जहां पर हमने देखा यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्ड
जो है किस तरीके से काम कर रहे हैं एंड वो
एक टेंपलेट का यूज़ कर रहे हैं। जनरली
इनपुट डॉट कॉन्फ नाम से हो सकता है मॉनिटर
करने के लिए स्पेसिफिक डायरेक्टरीज़ को।
एंड ये लॉग्स की लाइंस को पढ़ते हैं। एक
लाइटवेट फ्रेमिंग प्रोटोकॉल के अंदर उनको
रैप कर किया जाता है और स्ट्रीम कर दिया
जाता है TCP पोर्ट 597 पे। अब आगे की तरफ
है स्टेज बी हमारा। स्टेज बी में हैवी
पासिंग एंड डेटा रिडक्शन द ट्रैफिक कॉ। अब
इसमें क्या होता है? यह देखिए। बिफोर डेटा
हिट्स लॉन्ग टर्म डिस्क स्टोरेज इट पाससेस
थ्रू अ हैवी फॉरवर्डर। पहले हमने क्या
पढ़ा? यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर्स। ठीक है? अब आ
रहा है हमारा हैवी फॉरवर्ड्स। ठीक है?
और इंटरमीडिएट टायर टियर इंटरमीडिएट टियर।
अब यहां पे मतलब क्या है? बिफोर डेटा
हिट्स लॉन्ग टर्म डिस्क स्टोरेज। मतलब कि
जब डेटा एक्चुअली डिस्क में जाके सेव हो
जाती है हमेशा के लिए। उसके पहले की यह
बात है कि यह एक हाई हेवी फॉरवर्डर एचएफ
के थ्रू या इसको हम इंटरमीडिएट टियर बोलते
हैं। पास करता है। दिस इज़ अ क्रिटिकल
स्टेज फॉर एसओसी फाइनेंशियल एंड
परफॉर्मेंस बजटिंग। अब ये एक बहुत ही
क्रिटिकल स्टेज है एसओसी के फाइनेंसियल और
परफॉर्मेंस बजटिंग के लिए। क्योंकि देखो
एसओसी टीम का या एसओसी ऑपरेशन जो होती है
एसओसी की पूरी जो टीम होती है देखो एसओसी
अपने आप में सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन सेंटर अपने
आप में एक बहुत बड़ी टीम है। अब उस टीम को
मैनेज करना, उनकी उनके ऊपर एक्सपेंसेस,
फाइनेंससेस या उनकी सैलरीज ये सब कुछ या
वो जो मशीनंस सॉफ्टवेयर्स की जो आप
सॉफ्टवेयर्स यूज़ कर रहे हैं उनका आपको
चार्जेस देना होता है मंथली या इयरली
बेसिस पे। आप जो एडीआर यूज़ कर रहे हैं
उनका आपको चार्जेस देना पड़ता है। बहुत
ज्यादा एक्सपेंसेस आते हैं। अब ये
एक्सपेंसेस जो है ना वो डिसाइड की जाती है
टॉप जो कंपनीज़ की टॉप मैनेजमेंट है वो
डिसाइड करती है। ठीक है? एंड वो डिसाइड
करती है ये देख के कि भैया किस तरह का
परफॉर्मेंस एक्चुअली हो रहा है इन टीम के
द्वारा। एग्जैक्टली किस तरीके की काम यह
कर पा रहे हैं। उसके बेसिस पर उनका पूरा
का पूरा बजटिंग बनता है।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
तो अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पर
हैवी फॉरवर्ड्स के अंदर में अब यहां पे
किस तरीके से यह काम होती है तो डेटा
क्या-क्या काम होती है? डेटा फिल्टरिंग का
काम होता है और एनमाइजेशन एंड मास्किंग का
काम होता है। दो तरह के यहां पे आपके काम
होते हैं। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब देखिए
डेटा फ़िल्टरिंग में क्या होता है? अ एसओसी
इंजीनियर विल राइट रेजिकक्स रूल्स इनसाइड
प्रॉपs
ये एक फाइल है जिसके अंदर एसओसी इंजीनियर
जो है वो रेजिकक्स रूल्स राइट करेंगे
रेजिकक्स रूल्स एंड प्रोप्स प्रोप्स डॉट
कॉफ एंड ट्रांसफॉर्म्स डॉट कॉन्व टू
डिस्कार मिलियंस ऑफ जंक्स लॉग्स
ठीक है बिफोर दे टच द इंडेक्सर इंडेक्सर
को टच करने से पहले ही वो डिस्कार्ड हो
जाएंगे मतलब इंडेक्सर मतलब जो इंडेक्स
करता है सारे लॉग्स को सारी लॉग्स को एक
प्रॉपर वे में इंडेक्सिंग के थ्रू ठीक है
वो इंडेक्सिंग के थ्रू इंडेक्स करता है।
एक प्रॉपर वे में हायरार्की बनाता है ताकि
बहुत ज्यादा कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी और फालतू की
चीजें हमारे पास ना आ जाए। तो उसके लिए
क्या होता है? एसोसिएट इंजीनियर जो होते
हैं जो वो रेजिक्स रूल्स को लिखते हैं। अब
देखो एज एन एसोसिएट इंजीनियर अ आपके पास
आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी बढ़ जाती है। ठीक
है? मैंने पहले ही बोला था कि एसओसी L1 जो
है वो बहुत ही बेसिक रोल होता है।
जैसे-जैसे ऊपर जाएंगे ना L2, L3 इंजीनियर
बनेंगे तो आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी बढ़ जाती
है। वहां पे अब आपको स्क्रिप्टिंग भी करना
पड़ेगा। कोड्स भी लिखने पड़ सकते हैं।
अकॉर्डिंग टू द रिक्वायरमेंट अकॉर्डिंग टू
द डिटेक्शन रूल्स जो आपको बनाने हैं।
रिजेक्स रूल्स आपको लिखने पड़ सकते हैं।
राइट? ये सब कुछ। अब रेजिक्स रूल का मतलब
यह होता है कि
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एक पैटर्न के
अंदर में किसी बहुत बड़े डेटा सोर्स के
अंदर एक पैटर्न के साथ सर्च को करना
सर्चिंग करना ठीक है एक पैटर्न के साथ
उसको हम उसी को हम रिजिक्स रूल के अंदर
डिफाइन करते हैं। जैसे मान लो मेरे पास 1
टेराबाइट 10 टेराबाइट 20 टेराबाइट 50
टेराबाइट का डेटा है। ठीक है? अब मैं
उसमें एक-एक चीज थोड़ी ना खोजूंगा जाके।
तो मैं एक स्क्रिप्ट बनाऊंगा। एक रूल
क्रिएट करूंगा कि इस पर्टिकुलर डेटा के
अंदर डेटा सोर्स के अंदर में मुझे अगर
ऐसीऐसी चीजें मिल रही हैं तो उनको हटा दो
यहां से गायब कर दो। तो ये एक रूल क्रिएट
होता है। और वो क्यों बनाया जाता है? टू
डिस्कार मिलियंस ऑफ जंक लॉग्स ताकि जितने
भी बेकार के फालतू के लॉग्स हैं उनको
हटाया जा सके। मिलियंस ऑफ जंक लॉग्स को
डिस्कार्ड कर दिया जाए। क्योंकि जब लॉगिंग
होती है एंड पॉइंट्स के तरफ से तो बहुत
सारे बेफालतू के और बेकार के लॉग्स भी
लॉग्स लॉगिंग के थ्रू आ जाते हैं। जरूरी
नहीं है कि सारे लॉग्स अच्छे ही होंगे।
जरूरी नहीं है कि सारे लॉग्स जो होंगे वो
बढ़िया लॉग्स होंगे। प्रोसेसिंग के वाले
होंगे। जंक ऑफ गार्बेज लॉक्स भी आते हैं।
तो उनको ही हटाने के लिए रेजिक्स रूल्स
लिखे जाते हैं एसोसिएट इंजीनियर के
द्वारा। एग्जांपल के लिए यहां पे क्या है?
रूटीन फायर वॉल अलाउड
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कनेक्शन लॉक्स और डीबग नॉइस। ठीक है? मतलब
कि यहां पर रूटीन फायरवल जो है उसको अलऊ
करना है। यह इस टाइप के लॉग जो हैं उनको
मतलब कि रूटीन फायरवल है तो उसको क्यों हम
प्रोसेस करें? हम उन ऐसे तो जंक लॉग्स
कहलाएंगे ना। कोई अब रूटीन फायरवल का कोई
वो है नॉर्मल सा वो है। अगर वो भी आ रहा
है लॉग्स के अंदर में उस पे भी काम करने
लगे। तो हमारा ऑलरेडी जो डेली यूज में
फंक्शनैलिटी हो रहे हैं हमारे डिवाइसेस के
तरफ से हम उनका भी लॉग्स उनको भी अगर हम
प्रोसेस करने लगे तो वो हमारा टाइम वेस्ट
हो जाएगा। सिंपल सा सिंपल सा बात है। वो
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव में आ जाएगा टाइम वेस्ट हो
जाएगा। तो ऐसे लॉग्स को ट्राई किया जाता
है कि हटा दिया जाए रिजेक्स रूल्स के अंदर
मेंशन करके उनको डिफाइन करके।
दिस सेव्स मिलियंस ऑफ डॉलर्स इन इंजेशन
लाइसेंसिंग कॉस्ट। यह जो है यह मिलियंस ऑफ
डॉलर्स बताते हैं। बचाते हैं इंजेशन
लाइसेंसिंग कॉस्ट में। मतलब इंजेशन करने
वाली जो भी सॉफ्टवेयर्स या जो भी यूटिलिटी
यूज़ हो रही है उनके लाइसेंसिंग कॉस्ट को
बच कम कर देते हैं। ठीक है?
सर आई फाउंड अ बग इन अ क्लॉथ
शॉप इन अ क्लॉथ ब्रांड बट दे डोंट रिसोंड
माय मेल एंड द बग इज़ क्रिटिकल बग। उससे
कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता है। क्रिटिकल हो या
कुछ भी हो अगर वो रिसोंड नहीं करे तो उनकी
मर्जी है। यू कांट डू एनीथिंग इन दैट। ठीक
है? ज्यादा से ज्यादा अगर आप पब्लिक भी
करते हो तो दे कैन टेक एक्शन अगेंस्ट यू।
ठीक है। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। सर आधे घंटे लेट हो गई। रिकॉर्डिंग
पीछे करके देख रही हूं। कोई बात नहीं
बढ़िया है। अच्छी बात है। आप देखिए। ओके।
अभी [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आते हैं
एनोनमाइजेशन एंड मास्किंग। एनमाइजेशन एंड
मास्किंग में इफ अ लॉग कंटेन सेंसिटिव
पर्सनल इनेशन लाइक पीआईआई जैसे पर्सनली
आइडेंटिफायबल इनेशन जो होती है पीआईआई
लाइक क्लियर टेक्स्ट सोशल सिक्योरिटी
नंबर्स और क्रेडिट कार्ड्स द एचएफ हैवी
फॉरवर्डर इंटरसेप्ट्स इट एंड यूजेस द
रिजेक्स टू मास्क इट टू कंप्लाई विद द
प्राइवेसी फ्रेमवर्क्स लाइक जीडीपीआर
पीसीआई डीएसएस ईटीसी अब रेजिकक्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जो है रेजेक्स
रूल्स जो लिखे गए थे। ठीक है? रेजेक्स रूल
लिखी गई थी सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर के
द्वारा। तो अब उसका यूज़ यहां पे सेंसिटिव
इनेशन को मास्क करने के लिए भी लिया जाता
है। जैसे अगर कोई लॉग है। अब लॉग्स में
बहुत सारी चीजें आ सकती हैं। राइट? बहुत
सारी चीजें जनरेट हो सकती हैं लॉग्स के
अंदर में। अब उन लॉग्स में कोई पर्सनल
सेंसिटिव इनफेशन भी आ सकता है। पीआईआई
जिसको बोलते हैं पर्सनली आइडेंटिफायबल
इनेशन। अब ऐसी इनफेशन के साथ क्या करेंगे?
तो ऐसी इंफॉर्मेशन के साथ क्या होता है जो
आपका हैवी फॉरवर्डर होता है जो आपने ऊपर
में पढ़ा था यहां पर हैवी फॉरवर्डर ठीक है
वो क्या करता है इसको इंटरसेप्ट करता है
सेलॉग्स को एंड रेजिक्स रूल जो लिखी गई थी
उसका यूज़ करके उसको मास्क कर देता है
इनकोड कर देता है ताकि कोई जनरली इसको
प्लेन टेक्स्ट में ना देख पाए एंड इसलिए
करना होता है ये इंपॉर्टेंट मैंडेटरी चीज
है करना क्योंकि आपको जीडीपीआर पीसीआर
इडीएसएस ऐसे जो कंप्लायंसेस होते हैं इनके
साथ जो है आपको कंप्लाई करना ही पड़ता है।
इनके साथ जो है आपको कंप्लाई करके चलना
पड़ता है। अदरवाइज आपके अगेंस्ट जो है
आपकी कंपनी के अगेंस्ट भी आपको नोटिस आ
सकती है या आपका मतलब आप नॉन कंप्लायंस के
लिए आपके साथ दिक्कतें आ सकती है। इसलिए
जीडीपीआर वग़ैरह जो है यह सब भी सीरियस इशज़
है कि भाई आप किसी का अह अह अह पर्सनली
आइडेंटिफायबल इनेशन या पर्सनल सेंसिटिव
इनफेशन ऐसे ही थोड़ी ना छोड़ देंगे या लीक
करने देंगे या ऐसे ही लॉक के थ्रू कहीं भी
छोड़ते रहेंगे बांटते रहेंगे तो दिस इज़ नॉट
करेक्ट। तो ये इस तरीके से एनोनमाइजेशन
एंड मास्किंग का प्रोसेस भी आपका हैवी
फॉरवर्डर के द्वारा किया जाता है। ये था
स्टेज बी।
इसके बाद पहले क्या हुआ हमारा? पहले
कलेक्शन हुआ जो लॉग्स जो है थे उनका
कलेक्शन हुआ यूनिवर्सल फॉर ऑर्डर्स के
थ्रू हुआ। दूसरा है पार्सिंग और डाटा का
रिडक्शन मतलब उसको छांटा गया। छटनी हुई
उसकी मतलब फालतू के लॉग्स को फालतू जंक
लॉग्स को हटा दिया गया। पर्सनल
आइडेंटिफायबल इनेशन जो है सेंसिटिव इनेशन
उसको मास्क कर दिया गया। ठीक है? और डेटा
को पास कर दिया गया हैवी फॉर ऑर्डर के
थ्रू। अब तीसरा है हमारा स्टेज वो है
इंडेक्सिंग एंड स्टोरेज टाइम सीरीज
डेटाबेस। अब इंडेक्सिंग एंड स्टोरेज का
यहां पे प्रोसेस है। ठीक है? इंडेक्सिंग
एंड स्टोरेज में क्या होता है? आप देखिए।
अब इंडेक्सिंग इंडेक्सर के द्वारा किया
जाता है। इंडेक्सर्स जो होते हैं क्या
होता है? द स्प्लंक इंडेक्सर
ट्रांसफॉर्म्स रॉ टेक्स्ट स्ट्रेंट्स इनू
हाईली स्ट्रक्चरर्ड सर्चेबल डेटा। दिस इज़
वेयर द हैवी कंप्यूटेशनल लिफ्टिंग हैपेंस।
अब इस प्लंक में जो इंडेक्सेस आते हैं
उसकी लाइसेंसिंग होती है। कॉस्टिंग आती
है, पैसे लगते हैं। इसीलिए इंडेक्सेस का
काम कम करने के लिए यही पहले यहां पे
बताया गया था। यहां पे आपको मैंने बताया
कि इंडेक्स इंजेशन लाइसेंसिंग कॉस्ट। तो
अब इंडेक्सर जो है ना ये किस तरीके से काम
करता है? ये ट्रांसफॉर्म्स रॉ टेक्स्ट
स्ट्रीम्स। जो रॉ टेक्स्ट के स्ट्रीम्स
होते हैं उनको एक हाइली स्ट्रक्चरर्ड और
सर्चेबल डेटा में ट्रांसफॉर्म कर देता है।
एक स्ट्रक्चर तरीके से मतलब ऐसे ही बिखरा
पड़ा है डेटा लॉग्स बिखरे पड़े हैं। अब
उसको एक स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में क्या किया?
ऑर्गेनाइज कर दिया और एक सर्चेबल
स्ट्रक्चर तैयार कर दिया जिसमें कि आप
सर्च कर सकते हैं। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
अब इसमें दो तरह के फेजेस होते हैं। एक
होता है द पार्सिंग फेज और एक होता है द
बकेट लाइफ साइकिल। दोनों को समझते हैं।
पासिंग फेज क्या होता है? द इंडेक्सर
ब्रेक्स द टेक्स्ट स्ट्रीम इंटू डिस्क्रीट
इवेंट्स एक्सट्रैक्ट द एक्सप्लसिट यूटीसी
टाइम स्टैंप एंड टैग्स द डेटा विद कोर
मेटा डेटा। कोर मेटा डेटा लाइक होस्ट आपका
कहां से ये होस्ट मतलब जैसे कि होस्ट हो
गया। जैसे कहां से ये आया है? सोर्स द
फाइल पाथवे कहां कौन सा सोर्स था? सोर्स
टाइप। सोर्स का टाइप क्या था? लाइक लाइक
फॉर्मेट क्या था? वह सारी चीजें जो है यह
क्या करता है? इस उसको ऐसे वह तोड़ता है,
ब्रेकाउन करता है जो टेक्स्ट की स्ट्रीम
होती है। बहुत सारे बहुत सारे टेक्स्ट
पड़े हैं। बहुत सारे टेक्स्ट हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] टेक्स्ट का
गार्बेज है। तो उसको बहुत सारे तो जंक
वाले हटा दिए हैं। तो अब जो बच गए वो भी
बहुत सारे हैं। उनको डिस्क्रिप्ट इवेंट्स
में मतलब मतलब अलग-अलग स्ट्रक्चर में उनको
ब्रेकडाउन कर दिया। जिसमें से उसने एक
टाइम स्टैंप निकाल लिया। उसके बाद डेटा को
टैग कर दिया मेटा डेटा के साथ। क्या-क्या
टैगिंग में? जैसे होस्ट भाई कौन क्या
होस्ट कौन सा होस्ट था जहां से ये लॉग्स
लॉग आई है। सोर्स कौन सा आई मतलब आईपी या
कौन से सोर्स से कौन से मशीन से आई है वो
आ गया। होस्ट नेम क्या था वो आ गया। सोर्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
टाइप जैसे कि सोर्स टाइप में जैसे Sisco
एएसए और XML विन इवेंट लॉग तो सोर्स का
टाइप फॉर्मेट क्या था? तो Sisco से
रिलेटेड कोई लॉग थी या Windows इवेंट से
इवेंट लॉग से रिलेटेड कोई लॉक थी तो वो
सोर्स इस तरीके से वो डिवाइड कर देता है।
ठीक है? अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
दूसरी चीज़ होती है द बकेट लाइफ साइकिल।
क्या होता है? डेटा इज़ रिटेन टू टाइम
सीरीज डायरेक्टरीज़ ऑन डिस्क कॉल्ड बकेट्स।
अब अब जो है नेक्स्ट डेटा को पार्सिंग जब
हो जाती है तो अब डेटा को आफ्टर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
पार्सिंग अब डेटा को टाइम सीरीज
डायरेक्टरीज के अंदर जो है उसको राइट कर
दिया जाता है जिसको हम बकेट्स बोलते हैं।
अब ये टाइम सीरीज डायरेक्टरीज क्या है वो
अभी आपको मैं बताऊंगा। अब ये जो बकेट्स
होते हैं वो इस तरीके के टाइप्स के होते
हैं। हॉट बकेट्स, वार्म बकेट्स, कोल्ड
बकेट्स, फ्रोजन बकेट्स। ये बकेट्स होते
हैं। अलग-अलग टाइप के बकेट्स होते हैं।
ठीक है? अब ये क्या होते हैं भैया? हॉट
बकेट्स। तो एक्टिवली बीइंग रिटेन टू हेल्ड
इन सुपरस्ट स्टोरेज। जैसे कि एनवी एन
एनवीएमई या एसएसडी जो हैं जो बहुत ही
फास्ट स्टोरेज डिवाइसेस या हार्ड डिस्क
होते हैं। हॉट बकेट्स जो होते हैं उन्हीं
उन्हीं को कहा जाता है। मतलब उनके अंदर ही
वो डेटा जो है वो राइट किए जाते हैं। एंड
इसमें एक्टिवली डेटा को राइट किया जाता
है। मतलब राइट किया जाता है एकदम रेगुलर
बेसिस पे डेटा राइट्स होती रहती हैं।
एनवीएमई और एसएसडी जैसे डिवाइसेस में जो
कि काफी फास्ट डिवाइसेस होते हैं। ठीक है?
रीड राइट स्पीड काफी अच्छी होती है। उसके
बाद आते हैं वार्म बकेट्स जिसमें डेटा
स्टोर होती है। फुल हॉट बकेट्स रोल्ड ओवर।
मतलब यहां पे स्टिल ऑन फास्ट स्टोरेज
सर्चेबल बट नो लगर रिसीविंग न्यू एंट्रीज।
मतलब कि यहां पे वार्म बकेट्स का मतलब है
कि यह भी एक फास्ट स्टोरेज डिवाइसेस में
डेटा को राइड किया जाता है। बट इसका मतलब
है कि ये सर्चेबल भी होते हैं। मतलब ये भी
ऊपर हॉट बकेट्स भी सर्चेबल है। वार्म
बकेट्स में फुल हॉट बकेट्स मतलब जो हॉट
बकेट्स फुल हो चुके हैं। अब उनमें स्पेस
नहीं है। अब उनका काम वहां पे खत्म हो
गया। उन अभी और फ़र्दर उसमें अब राइट नहीं
करना। फर्दर डाटा को नहीं डालना है तो अब
बस वह वार्म बकेट जो है वह कहलाती है। अब
उसमें कोई नई एंट्री नहीं आ रही है। वह
होते हैं वार्म बकेट्स। अब आते हैं कोल्ड
बकेट्स। ओल्डर डेटा मूव्ड टू चीप हाई
कैपेसिटी मैकेनिकल और क्लाउड ऑब्जेक्ट
स्टोरेज सर्चिंग टेक सिग्निफिकेंटली लगर।
अब देखो हॉट और वार्म बकेट्स में क्या
होता है? हॉट
पर बकेट्स इंपॉर्टेंट क्यों है? बकेट्स
क्यों इंपॉर्टेंट है? वो स्टोरेज डिवाइस
है भाई। यहां बकेट्स का मतलब है हम उन
डेटा को स्टोर कर रहे हैं। वी आर स्टोरिंग
दोज़ डेटाज़। ठीक है? हमें कहीं ना कहीं जो
मान लो यार कहीं ना कहीं हमारे पास जब
लॉग्स आते हैं जो लॉग्स जनरेट होते हैं
उसको कहीं ना कहीं स्टोर तो करोगे ना। कोई
भी डेटा कहीं स्टोर होगी या नहीं होगी? यह
बताइए आप लोग। कहीं ना कहीं तो स्टोर
होगी। तो वो स्टोरेज का ही फंक्शनैलिटी है
बकेट लाइफ साइकिल के थ्रू जो मैं आपको
समझा रहा हूं। अब इतने सारे लॉग्स होते
हैं। इतने सारी डेटा होती हैं। उनको स्टोर
करके रखना तो पड़ेगा ना ताकि वो सर्चेबल
हो ताकि उसमें सर्च किया जा सके। फास्ट भी
हो, एक्सेसिबल हो। तो सबसे पहले हॉट
बकेट्स को रखा जाता है जो सबसे फास्ट होते
हैं जिसमें हमेशा डेटा राइट हो रही होती
है। करंट में हो रही है डेटा राइट। वार्म
बकेट्स जो हॉट हॉट बकेट जो फुल हो चुके
हैं। वार्म बकेट्स हैं वो भी फास्ट एसएसडी
वाले ही होते हैं। ठीक है? कोल्ड बकेट्स।
अब कोल्ड बकेट जो होता है वो होते हैं अब
मान लो कोई ओल्डर डेटा है पुराना डेटा है।
अब जैसे पुराने अगर ये डेटा हैं तो उनको
चीप चीप स्टोरेज डिवाइसेस में मूव कर
दिया। जैसे अब मान लो एसएसडी ना यूज़ करके
हार्ड डिस्क का यूज़ किया जा रहा है। अब
हार्ड डिस्क जो है काफी सस्ती मिलती है।
अब मान लो एक टेराबाइट का SSD आप जितने
प्राइस में खरीदोगे उतनी ही प्राइस में
हार्ड डिस्क लगभग तीन चार टेराबाइट की भी
मिल सकती है। आपको कंपनी टू कंपनी डिपेंड
करती है। तो अब एक ओल्डर डाटा जो होते हैं
उनको हाई कैपेसिटी हार्ड डिस्कस या
मैकेनिकल डिवाइसेस जो भी होते हैं या
क्लाउड ऑब्जेक्ट स्टोरेज या क्लाउड में
कहीं पे सस्ता क्लाउड कहीं पे स्टोरेज मिल
रहा है वहां पे डाल दिया जाता है। अब जब
भी कोई स्लो डिवाइस में डेटा को डाला जाता
है तो सर्चिंग काफी ज्यादा धीरे हो जाती
है। फास्ट डिवाइसेस में सर्चिंग काफी
फास्ट होती है। उसके बाद आते हैं फ्रोजन
बकेट्स। फ्रोजन बकेट्स मतलब होते हैं यह
एक्सपायर्ड डेटा। फ्रोजन का मतलब होता है
यहां पर एक्सपायर डाटा। ओके
सोमोजीत दास सर थोड़ा टाइम कम करो ना ढाई
3 घंटा नहीं होता फास्ट में पीछे हूं।
ऑनेस्टली कर रहा हूं विदाउट स्किपिंग।
देखिए आप पीछे हैं। आप उसको कवर कीजिए।
बिल्कुल कवर कीजिए और यहां तक आप पहुंचिए
जल्दी से। फ्रोजन बकेट्स में होते हैं
एक्सपायर्ड डेटा। डिलीटेड एंटायरली और
कंप्रेस्ड एन आर्काइव्ड ऑफ़ साइट अनसर्चेबल
विदाउट मैनुअल रिंडेक्सिंग। अब फ़ोजन
बकेट्स मतलब कि मतलब एक तो सर्च आप नहीं
कर सकते। उसमें डिलीटेड पूरी डिलीटेड डेटा
या कंप्रेस्ड डेटा होते हैं और एक्सपायर
या एक्सपायर डेटा होते हैं। वो फ्रोजन
बकेट्स में रख दिए जाते हैं। ठीक है? तो
ये हमारा था इंडेक्सिंग एंड स्टोरेज का
पार्ट। ठीक है? जिसमें कि हमने बकेट्स और
पार्सिंग के बारे में समझा। तो अभी तक
हमने तीन स्टेज देखे थे। कलेक्शन, हैवी
पासिंग एंड डाटा रिडक्शन, इंडेक्सिंग एंड
स्टोरेज। इस तरीके से जो है आपका प्रॉपर
यह एसआईएम आपका काम करता है। अब आते हैं
यहां पे इसके बाद आती है डेटा
नॉर्मलाइजेशन। यहां तो हमारी क्या हो गई?
हमारी यहां पे जो चीजें हुई हैं वो
कलेक्शन डेटा का हुआ है। उसको पास करके
पास करके हैवी फॉरवर्ड कलेक्शन वाले में
यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर पास करने में हैवी
फॉरवर्डर का यूज़ हुआ है। जहां पे फालतू
डेटा को हटाया गया और अच्छी जो सही डेटा
है उनको ही बस रखा गया है। इंडेक्स किया
गया। उनको मतलब उनको
लाइक जो भी सेंसिटिव इनेशन वगैरह है उनको
हटाया गया। डेटा को एक तरह से फ़्टर किया
गया। फिल्ट्रेशन प्रोसेस किया गया। ठीक
है?
और लास्ट में हमारा है इंडेक्सिंग। उन अब
जब फिल्टर-उल्टर हो के आ गई है तो डेटा को
हमने इंडेक्स किया। एक एक स्ट्रक्चर में
उसको स्टोर कर दिया बकेट्स के अकॉर्डिंग।
ठीक है? इन सब के बाद जो है नेक्स्ट स्टेप
है आपका डेटा नॉर्मलाइजेशन का। जिसको हम
स्प्लक सीआईएम के अगर कॉन्टेक्स्ट में बात
करें कॉमन इंफॉर्मेशनेशन मॉडल। तो डेटा
नॉर्मलाइजेशन क्या होती है? इसको हम समझते
हैं। देखो, रॉ सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स फ्रॉम
डिफरेंट टूल्स यूज़ कंप्लीटली डिफरेंट
नेमिंग कन्वेंशंस फॉर द एग्जैक्ट सेम
कॉनंसेप्ट्स। अब देखो, अलग-अलग सिक्योरिटी
टूल्स या अलग-अलग टूल्स से जो हमारे पास
लॉग्स आते हैं। ठीक है? सिक्योरिटी लॉग जो
आते हैं। ठीक? उनके नाम या उनके तरीके
अलग-अलग हो सकते हैं। उनको वो जो लॉग्स
आने का जो वे होता है, जो नेमिंग होता है,
जो तरीका अप्रोच होता है, वो अलग-अलग हो
सकता है। बट ऐसे कैसे काम चलेगा? क्योंकि
एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड तो एक ही है। तो वहां
हमें यह भी चाहिए, यह भी चाहिए कि हमारे
पास जो लॉग्स आ रहे हैं,
जो जनरेट हो के आ रही हैं, वह एक ही टाइप
के
मतलब सिंटेक्स में हो, एक ही टाइप के
नेमिंग में हो, एक ही टाइप के वर्डिंग में
हो जो सबके लिए कॉमन हो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
या अगर ना हो तो उसको उस तरीके से कन्वर्ट
कर दिया जाए। वही होता है। वही काम होता
है
डेटा नॉर्मलाइजेशन के अंदर में। ठीक है?
अब कैसे होता है?
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
देखो, इफ एन एंटप्राइज यूसेस पैलो Alto
फायर वाल्स। मान लो pलो Alto का फायरवल
कोई कंपनी यूज़ कर रहा है। जेड स्केलर
वेपक्स एब्ल्यूएस बीपीसी फ्लो लॉग्स और
रूटीन कनेक्शन ब्लॉक अ रूटीन कनेक्शन
ब्लॉक लुक्स एंटायरली डिफरेंट अक्रॉस ऑल
थ्री सिस्टम। अब इन तीनों का ना लॉग जो
आएगा वह अलग-अलग दिखता है। अलग-अलग लॉग्स
आते हैं। इफ एन एनालिस्ट वांट्स टू राइट अ
रूल टू चेक फॉर अ ब्लॉक्ड आईपी अक्रॉस द
एंटायर कंपनी दे वुड हैव टू राइट अ
मैसिवली कॉम्प्लेक्स क्वेरी अकाउंटिंग फॉर
एव्री सिंगल वेंडर्स स्पेसिफिक वोकैबलरी।
और अगर आप अगर अब यहां पे एक एनालिस्ट को
एक रूल लिखना हो या इंजीनियर को रूल लिखना
हो कि ब्लॉग्ड आईपी को चेक करने के लिए
पूरे कंपनी के लिए तो उसको हर इन टूल्स के
लिए ना अलग-अलग हर इन टूल्स के लॉग्स के
अकॉर्डिंग अलग-अलग तरीके से उसको लिखना
पड़ेगा जो कि बहुत ही कॉम्प्लेक्स टास्क
हो जाएगा। जैसे आप पैलो ऑल्टो की बात करें
तो उनके लॉग्स में कुछ इस तरीके के नेम्स
होते हैं, वर्डिंग्स होते हैं। एक्शन =
डिनाई सोर्स इज इक्वल टू ये मतलब इस सोर्स
आईपी से अगर किसी तरह का कोई एक्शन होता
है या किसी तरह का कोई रिक्वेस्ट आता है
तो उसको डिनाई कर देना है। इसका मतलब यह
हुआ। ठीक है? जेड स्केलर में यही चीज कैसे
आती है? ब्लॉक टाइप पॉलिसी ब्लॉक्ड
क्लाइंट आईपी यह अब सेम देखो यहां पे मतलब
एक ही है कि इस क्लाइंट आईपी से कोई कोई
इंफॉर्मेशन लेने की कोशिश की जा रही है या
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है तो उसको यहां पे ब्लॉक
कर दिया जाए बट दोनों का जो नेमिंग और
दोनों का जो बोलने का तरीका जो जो इसको
रिप्रेजेंट करने का तरीका है वो डिफरेंट
है। एडब्ल्यूएस वीपीसी में क्या जाता है?
लॉग स्टेटस रिजेक्ट सोर्स एसआरसी एड्रेस
यह इसमें भी सोर्स एड्रेस जो है वह आपको
दिया हुआ है क्लाइंट का एड्रेस और यहां पे
इसको भी रिजेक्ट किया। तो देखो तीनों में
एक ही चीज है। इस लॉक का एक ही मतलब है कि
इस आईपी से कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन लेने की
कोशिश की जा रही है या किसी तरह की
एक्टिविटी हो रही है तो उसको ब्लॉक कर दो।
लेकिन तीनों का नेमिंग अलग-अलग है। अब ऐसे
अगर किसी एसोसिएट इंजीनियर को लिखना पड़े,
रूल्स लिखना पड़े एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट को तो
उसको अलग-अलग लिखने पड़ेंगे। तो ऐसे तो
बहुत कॉम्प्लेक्स हो जाएगा। यही प्रॉब्लम
को सॉल्व करता है डेटा नॉर्मलाइजेशन
प्रोसेस। कैसे मैं आपको अगले स्लाइड में
दिखाता हूं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए
सॉलशन है फील्ड एलियसिंग एंड टैगिंग। इसका
सशन यही है कि फील्ड एलियसिंग और टैगिंग
स्प्लंक जैसा टूल जो होता है जो स्प्लंक
की हम यहां पे बात कर रहे हैं। मोस्टली हम
अपने एसओसी की जो क्लासेस हैं उसमें अगर
हम बात करते हैं एसआईएम किसी टूल के बारे
में तो हम स्प्लक को ज्यादातर बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट
लेके चलेंगे। स्प्लंक सॉल्व्स दिस वाया द
कॉमन इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल इंफॉर्मेशनेशन मॉडल।
सीआईएम स्प्ल जो है इसको सीआईएम के थ्रू
सॉल्व करता है। कॉमन इनेशन मॉडल ड्यूरिंग
सर्च टाइम एग्जीक्यूशन
डेटा मॉडल मैपिंग्स रन इन द बैकग्राउंड।
ठीक है? जब ये सर्च टाइम एग्जीक्यूशन होती
है तो डेटा मॉडल मैपिंग बैकग्राउंड में रन
होती है। स्प्लक कन्वर्ट्स ऑल दोज़ मैसी
वेंडर वेरिएबल्स इंटू स्टैंडर्ड यूनिवर्सल
फील्ड्स। अब स्प्लक क्या करता है कि जितने
ये अलग-अलग ये सब आ रहे थे ना इन सबको एक
स्टैंडर्ड वेरिएबल स्टैंडर्ड जो है ना एक
फील्ड्स में कन्वर्ट कर देता है स्टैंडर्ड
फील्ड्स में जैसे अब यहां पे तुम देख
रहेगे कि इनमें एक्शन एक्शन की बात हो रही
थी एक्शन इक्वल टू डिनाई राइट ये आया तो
यहां पे एक्शन को इन्होंने ब्लॉक्ड कर
दिया एक्शन वर्ड का एलियास एक वर्ड बना
दिया मतलब उसका उसकी जगह पे एलियास का
मतलब है उसकी जगह पे एक वर्ड बना दिया
ब्लॉक्ड मतलब अब एक्शन यूज़ नहीं होगा।
ब्लॉक्ड यूज़ होगा। एंड सोर्स आईपी को अब
यहां पे अलग-अलग था। जैसे कहीं पे क्लाइंट
आईपी था, कहीं पे एसआरसी एड्रेस था, कहीं
पे एसआरसी था। तो इसको बना दिया सोर्स
आईपी। एसआरसी आईपी। तो, अब ये दोनों जो है
कॉमन हो गया। क्या हो गया भैया यहां पे?
कि एक्शन इक्वल टू ब्लॉक्ड हो गया। और यह
सोर्स आईपी हो गई। तो, अब बिकॉज़ द डेटा इज़
नॉर्मलाइज़। अब यह नॉर्मलाइज़ हो चुका है।
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट कैन राइट वन सिंगल हाइली
कॉनसाइज़ क्वरी दैट फ़िल्टर्स अक्रॉस ऑल
सिक्योरिटी वेंडरर्स साइमलटेनियसली। अब वो
क्या लिखेगा? पहले यहां पे तीन अलग-अलग
क्वरीज़ थे। अब एक क्वरी क्या लिखेंगी? टैग
इक्वल टू नेटवर्क। टैग इज़ इक्वल टू
कम्युनिकेट एक्शन इज़ इक्वल टु ब्लॉक्ड। अब
यहां पे क्या आ रहा है? सीधा एक्शन
ब्लॉक्ड।
एक्शन हमारा क्या हो गया? ब्लॉक्ड हो गया।
और एसआरसी आईपी सोर्स आईपी ये आ गई। सोर्स
आईपी क्या हो गया? हमारा जो आईपी था तो अब
यहां पे एक सिंपल सा ये एक
क्वरी बन चुका है जो सारे वेंडर्स पे काम
करेगी। चाहे आप पैलो Alto का लॉग हो, Z
स्केलर से लॉग हो, AWS VPC से लॉग हो या
किसी भी वेंडर से लॉग हो ये सब पे काम
करेगा। क्योंकि यहां पे हमने कॉमन नेमिंग
स्कीम बना दिया। इसी को हम डेटा
नॉर्मलाइजेशन बोलते हैं। ये नॉर्मलाइजेशन
का प्रोसेस हो गया। जहां पे
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट नेमिंग स्कीम को हटा के
एक कॉमन स्ट्रक्चर नेमिंग स्कीम लाया गया।
जहां पे हमने एक एलियास बनाया। फील्ड
एलियासिंग इसी को बोलते हैं। फील्ड
एलियासिंग और टैगिंग जहां पे हमने टैग
किया कि भाई एसआरसी आईपी ही हमारा सोर्स
आईपी है। तो इस तरीके से तो आई होप कि
यहां आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। एवरीवन
अंडरस्टुड प्लीज लेट मी नो।
सर आपकी हेल्थ खराब होने के बाद भी
क्लासेस ले रहे हो। सो यू आर डिफरेंट।
थैंक यू वेरी मच आप इतना अगर आप लोगों को
समझ में आ रहा है तो आई होप कि आप लोग
कंटिन्यू करेंगे। बट फिर भी अभी कहां है?
50 लोग भी नहीं रहते हैं। 50 लोग भी नहीं
है लाइव में। आई डोंट नो कि क्या है। बट
लेट इट बी।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
आप [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सभी समझ
गए इसका पूरा कांसेप्ट
प्रैक्टिकल सिखाओ। प्रैक्टिकल वाले यहां
से भाग लो जल्दी से जल्दी से निकल लो
प्रैक्टिकल वाले
आर यू गेटिंग
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अरे अरे रचित त्यागी, क्या बात है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलिए, [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
नेक्स्ट आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं। सभी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लोग लाइक ठोक
दिया ना सबने? लाइक ठोका है सबने? लाइक
ठोक दिया हो शायद। चलो आगे की तरफ बढ़ते
हैं। अब यहां पे ये प्रोसेस पूरा कंप्लीट
होता है। अब इसके बाद जब डाटा नॉर्मलाइज
होती है तब आती है अलर्टिंग का प्रोसेस।
जो आप अलर्ट एसआईएम से आपको अलर्ट मिलता
है ना वो अलर्टिंग का प्रोसेस सबसे लास्ट
का प्रोसेस है।
ठीक है? तो हमने शुरू किया था लॉग्स के
कलेक्शन से पार्सिंग के तरफ से होते हुए
इंडेक्सिंग होते हुए नॉर्मलाइजेशन होते
हुए। अब हम लास्ट यहां पे पहुंचे हैं कहां
पे? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अलर्टिंग के
प्रोसेस। यहां पे अलर्ट आता है।
ओके। बग बंटी की सीरीज आप देखिए। अ
दैट इज अ बग बंटी सीरीज बट यू विल गेट टू
नो अ लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स। ठीक है?
चलिए अलर्टिंग प्रोसेस में रियल टाइम
कोरिलेशन इंजन के बारे में हम जानने वाले
हैं। क्या होता है ये? देखिए। वंस लॉग्स
आर सिक्योरली इंडेक्स्ड एंड नॉर्मलाइज्ड।
अब लॉग्स जब सिक्योरली इंडेक्स्ड हो गए
हैं, नॉर्मलाइज हो गए हैं, पूरे प्रॉपर
फॉर्मेट में आ चुके हैं। एक प्रॉपर
स्ट्रक्चर में आ चुके हैं। द एसआईएम
स्विचेस फ्रॉम अ पैसिव रिपोजिटरी टू एन
एक्टिव रियल टाइम थ्रेड डिटेक्शन इंजन। अब
एसआईएम क्या करता है कि अपने आप को एक
रेपोजिटरी के तौर पे ना करके अपने आप को
रेपोजिटरी की तरह ना बना के पैसिव
रेपोजिटरी की तरफ ना बना के। अब यह एक
एक्टिव रियल टाइम थ्रेट डिटेक्शन मशीन की
तरह काम करने लगता है। सबसे पहले एसआईएम
हमारा बहुत स्मार्ट है। एसआईएम क्या करता
है? सबसे पहले तो लॉग्स को आने देता है।
उस पे सारे कलेक्शन का काम, पार्सिंग का
काम, नॉर्मलाइजेशन का काम ये सारा काम
स्ट्रक्चरिंग इंडेक्सिंग का काम सारा काम
कर लेता है। जब यह सारा काम हो जाता है तब
वो अपने दूसरे रूप में आता है जिसका नाम
है थ्रेट डिटेक्शन। रियल टाइम थ्रेट
डिटेक्शन वाला रूप जो कि इसका सबसे ज्यादा
ओजी रूप होता है। ठीक है? डेंजरस रूप
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
डेंजरस रूप होता है। अब उस ये डेंजरस रूप
में आता है। अब सोचो डेंजरस रूप में आके
ये क्या करेगा? एग्जैक्टली अभी तक तो ये
बहुत ही नॉर्मल सा प्यारा सा बच्चा बनके
था। एकदम से नॉर्मल अह प्रोसेसिंग वगैरह
कर रहा था। सब कुछ कर रहा था। ये सब सारी
चीजें कर रहा था। अभी डेंजरस रूप में आके
क्या करेगा? देखते हैं। दिस इज़ हैंडल्ड
बाय कोरिलेशन सर्चेस रनिंग इनसाइड स्प्लक
एंटरप्राइज सिक्योरिटी।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ठीक है? अब
स्प्लक जो टूल है स्प्लंक एंटरप्राइज उसके
अंदर में कोरिलेशन सर्चेस होते हैं जो
चलते हैं। इसके अंदर में स्प्लक टूल के
अंदर में कोरिलेशन सर्चेस होते हैं। वो
चलते रहते हैं। वो इस पार्ट को हैंडल करते
हैं। जो ये आपका कौन सा पार्ट है? थ्रेट
डिटेक्शन वाला पार्ट है। दीज़ सर्चेस
एग्जीक्यूट ऑन एन ऑटोमेटेड बैकग्राउंड
क्रॉन शेड्यूल। क्रोन शेड्यूल क्रोन के
बारे में मैंने बताया था। अगर आपको नहीं
पता पिछले वीडियोस में मैंने बताया था
क्रोन रिलेटेड चीजें। क्रोन क्या काम करती
है। लinक्स में बताया था मैंने आपको। तभी
तो वो सारी क्लासेस मैंने आपकी ली थी ताकि
आपको सारी चीजों का आईडिया पहले लग जाए।
एंड देन हम जब एसआईएम के डैशबोर्ड पे
आएंगे तो वो चीजें आप विजुअलाइज़ कर
पाएंगे। वो चीज़ आप समझ पाएंगे। राइट?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तो क्रॉन शेड्यूल यह जो सर्चेस एग्जीक्यूट
होते हैं, यह एक ऑटोमेटेड बैकग्राउंड
क्रॉन शेड्यूल बना होता है। उसी के बेसिस
पर होते हैं। जैसे एव्री 5 मिनट्स चेकिंग
द प्रीवियस 5 मिनट्स ऑफ लॉक्स। मतलब इसका
ऐसा एक क्रोन जॉब बना होता है। ऑटोमेटेड
शेड्यूल्ड होता है कि हर 5 मिनट पे पिछले
5 मिनट के लॉक्स को चेक करो। हर 5 मिनट पे
पिछले 5 मिनट के लॉक्स को चेक करो। यूजिंग
एसएल यूजिंग एसएल सर्च प्रोसेसिंग
लैंग्वेज। यहां पे एसआईएम टूल्स के अंदर
में यहां पे बेसिकली स्प्लन की बात कर रहा
हूं तो यहां पे एसएल सर्च प्रोसेसिंग
लैंग्वेज जो है वो जनरली यूज़ लिया जाता है
एंड इसी के थ्रू ये सारी सर्चिंग और ये
सारी चीजें जो है एग्जीक्यूट करी जाती है।
तो इस तरीके से यह सर्च किए जाते हैं बाय
द कोरिलेशन सर्चेस। अब यहां पे उसके बाद
आता है द इंसिडेंट रिव्यू एंड एनालिसिस
लाइफ साइकिल। व्हेन द कोरिलेशन सर्चेस
मीट्स इट्स स्पेसिफिक पैराटर्स जब
कोरिलेशन चल रहा होता है एकदम कंटिन्यू
रियल टाइम में चल रहा होता है और वो एक
स्पेसिफिक पैरामीटर को पैरामीटर को मीट
करता है इट फायर्स अ नोटेबल इवेंट और उसी
टाइम वो एक इवेंट को फायर करता है इनसाइड
स्प्लंक ट्रैग पेन जो स्प्लंक का ट्रैग
वाला पेन है जो स्टार्टिंग मैंने आपको
इमेज के थ्रू बताया था यह वाला यह आपको
दिख रहा होगा यह ये जो आपको यहां पे दिख
रहा है ये अ जो ये पूरा सेक्शन वाइज
डिवाइडेड जो आ रहा है यहां पे कि ये ट्रैग
वाला जो पेन तो ये ट्रैग पेन में क्या
करता है आपको थ्रो करता है। अब यहां पे
स्प्लंक [हंसी] का तो जैसे ये कोरिलेशन
कोरिलेशन सर्चेस चलते रहते हैं। स्प्लंक
के अंदर में रियल टाइम डिटेक्शन होती रहती
है। रियल टाइम डिटेक्शन के लिए चालू रहता
है। चलता रहता है। भाई कोई थ्रेट आ रहे
हैं डिटेक्ट करेंगे भैया हम और उसमें
ऑटोमेटेड एक क्रॉन जॉब चलता रहता है। यहां
पे ऑटोमेटेड जो है वो लॉक्स की चेकिंग
होती रहती है। कुछ-कुछ देर पे कुछ-कुछ देर
पे उसमें एसएल का यूज़ किया जाता है। सर्च
प्रोसेसिंग लैंग्वेज को यूज़ किया जाता है।
राइट? तो अब ये जो सर्च चलते रहते हैं तो
उनको कोई मान लो कोई एक रूल बना है
डिटेक्शन रूल। अब ये जो डिटेक्शंस होते
हैं ये डिटेक्शन रूल्स के ऊपर डिटेक्शन
रूल्स के ऊपर काम करते हैं। डिटेक्शन
रूल्स को एसोसिएट इंजीनियर्स बनाते हैं,
राइट करते हैं कि भैया अगर ये चीज हो तो
ये डिटेक्ट हो। ये चीज हो तो ऐसा डिटेक्ट
हो। ऐसा होता है डिटेक्शन रूल में ऐसा
होता है कि पांच फेल्ड लॉगिन अटेम्प्ट के
बाद आप ये इवेंट फायर करो कि हां मल्टीपल
फेल्ड लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट्स ऐसा भी होता है
कि अगर पांच बार फेल लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट हुआ
तो तुरंत अलर्ट फायर हो जाएगा। तो ये
डिटेक्शंस होते हैं। तो जैसे ही वो
पैरामीटर्स मीट करते हैं ये नोटेबल इवेंट
फायर करता है। यानी कि यहां पे इवेंट फायर
करने का मतलब यहां पे अलर्ट से ही है।
यहां पे अलर्ट से है ये इवेंट फायर होने
का मतलब।
हां जी। एसआईएम हर कंपनी में अलग-अलग हो
सकती हैं। एसआईएम सॉलशंस हर कंपनी अलग-अलग
यूज़ कर सकती है। ठीक है? पॉपुलर है।
स्प्लंक वगैरह जो है ये सेंटिनल वन वगैरह
ये सब पॉपुलर टूल्स है। वाजू एक ओपन सोर्स
टूल है। उसको भी काफी लोग यूज़ करते हैं।
सो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अलग-अलग
हो सकता है। [हंसी]
तो अब ये इवेंट फायर जो हुआ ये अलर्ट का
ही बात हो रहा है। यहां पे अलर्ट फायर
हुआ। इंसाइड स्प्ल ट्रैक पेन। दिस किक्स
ऑफ द कोर ह्यूमन ऑपरेशंस पाइपलाइन ऑफ़ द
एसओसी। अब जैसे ही अलर्ट फायर हुआ तो
ह्यूमन ऑपरेशंस यानी कि ह्यूमन ऑपरेशंस
फायर यहां हो जाते हैं। ह्यूमन ऑपरेशंस का
मतलब क्या है? क्या होता है? ह्यूमन
ऑपरेशंस का मतलब क्या होता है? अलर्ट फायर
हुआ तो ह्यूमन ऑपरेशन स्टार्ट हो रहे हैं।
इसका मतलब क्या हुआ? इस लाइन का मतलब क्या
कहना चाह रहा है? ये ह्यूमन ऑपरेशन फायर
हुआ। इसका मतलब क्या हुआ? बताइए आप लोग।
ह्यूमन ऑपरेशंस स्टार्ट हो रहे हैं। इसका
मतलब क्या हुआ? अलर्ट फायर होने के बाद
एवरीवन लेट मी नो। देखते हैं कितने लोग
बताते हैं कुछ।
सो जो है अभी इंटरव्यू वाली मैं लाऊंगा
क्लासेस तो उसमें मैं बहुत डिटेल में बात
करूंगा। ठीक है? अभी
ज्यादा उस पे बात नहीं करेंगे। उसमें उस
टाइम पे बहुत कुछ बात करेंगे। ठीक है?
हां। मतलब कि एसओसी एनालिस्ट का काम शुरू
हो रहा है यहां पे। बिल्कुल सही बात है।
अब एसोसिए एनालिस्ट जो है वो अपना ह्यूमन
इंटेलिजेंस यूज करके अपनी स्किल्स को यूज
करके आगे के प्रोसेससेस जो है आगे के जो
स्टेप्स हैं वो करना शुरू कर देगा। ठीक
है? द एसआईएम ऑटोमेटिकली पाससेस आउट द कोर
फील्ड्स। एसआईएम ऑटोमेटिकली कोड फ्ल्स को
पास कर देता है इनवॉल्वड जैसे कि यूजर को
यूजर के बारे में बताना सोर्स आईपी के
बारे में बताना होस्ट के बारे में बताना
एंड क्रॉस रेफरेंसेस देम अगेंस्ट इंटरनल
कॉर्पोरेट lookups इन रियल टाइम जो
lookअप्स बने होते हैं जो लook्स के बारे
में मैंने आपको बताया था वर्क बक्स एंड
lookups ठीक है वर्क बुक्स एंड lookups के
बारे में तो उस lookups के अगेंस्ट में वो
क्या करता है क्रॉस रेफरेंसेस चेक करता है
एंड उसके एंड ऑटोमेटिकली पास करके वो एक
स्ट्रक्चर वे में जो है अलग-अलग कर देता
है। जो अह जो भी अह लॉग्स होती हैं उसको
यूज़र्स अलग बताता है। सोर्स आईपी अलग
बताएगा। उसमें होस्ट अलग बताएगा सब कुछ।
बिफोर एन एनालिस्ट इवन क्लिक्स ऑन द टिकट।
द एसआईएम हैज़ ऑलरेडी फ्लैग दैट। मतलब अभी
तो एनालिस्ट का काम अब तो स्टार्ट होगा
अलर्ट के बाद। लेकिन उसके पहले ही एसआईएम
उसको फ्लैग कर चुका होता है कि भैया यहां
कुछ तो गड़बड़ी है। कुछ तो प्रॉब्लम है।
साडू के कुछ यहां पे कुछ तो दिक्कत है वो
वाली प्रॉब्लम। ठीक है? द यूजर अकाउंट
बिलोंग्स टू द वीपी ऑफ़ ग्लोबल फाइनेंस द
होस्ट मशीन टारगेटेड होल्ड्स पीसीआई
कंप्लाइट फाइनेंसियल डाटा। मतलब इस तरीके
से फ्लैग करके कुछ इस तरीके की
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन प्रोवाइड कर देता है हमारा
एसआईएम कि भैया हां डी यूजर अकाउंट जो है
वीपी ग्लोबल फाइनेंस से ये बिलॉन्ग करते
हैं और होस्ट मशीन जो है वो अ होस्ट मशीन
टारगेटेड होल्स पीसीआई कंप्लेंट
फाइनेंसियल डाटा होल्ड करते हैं जो होस्ट
मशीन जिस पे टारगेट हुआ है तो कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन जो है एसआईएम की तरफ से
ऑलरेडी दे दिया जाता है कि भैया एक
फाइनेंस वाला डिपार्टमेंट है एक आपका
कंप्लाइट वाले डिपार्टमेंट का डाटा है इन
सब पे भी जो है कुछ अटैक्स हो सकते हैं या
होने वाले वाले हैं तो अपना रेडी हो जाइए
और अपना काम शुरू कर दीजिए। अब यहां से
एसओसी का जो है अपना काम शुरू हो जाता है
एंड दे स्टार्ट द प्रोसेससेस।
यह पूरा का पूरा प्रोसेस आपका होता है एक
एसआईएम के अंदर में। अब हम आगे की तरफ
बढ़ेंगे। तो अगर हम बात करें हाउ एसआईएम
एक्चुअली इंटीग्रेट्स
द इकोसिस्टम। पूरे इकोसिस्टम को कैसे
इंडीग्रेट करता है? तो हम दोनों एसआईएम
यहां पे हम स्प्लंक की बात कर रहे हैं।
ठीक है? एसआईएम यहां पे हम स्प्लक की बात
कर रहे हैं और यहां पे ईडीआर जो है वो हम
एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन की बात कर रहे हैं।
ठीक है? ईडीआर की बात कर रहे हैं। अब यहां
पे एसआईएम
कैपेबिलिटीज़ की हम यहां पे बात करेंगे।
एसआईएम की कैपेबिलिटीज़ के ऊपर देखते हैं
पहले। फिर हम उस कैपेबिलिटीज़ को प्लंक और
ईडीआर के थ्रू अलग-अलग डील करेंगे। ठीक
है? चलिए स्कोप ऑफ साइट क्या होता है?
पहले [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हम
कैपेबिलिटीज़ को लेके बात करें। कुछ लोग
पूछ रहे थे ईडीआर वगैरह के बारे में। ठीक
है ना? कि ईडीआर एग्जैक्टली ईडीआर का क्या
सीन है? अह ईडीआर
यूज़ तो कर ही रहे हैं। तो हम फिर एसआईएम
को क्यों यूज़ करेंगे? राइट? इस तरीके की
बात है। तो यहां पर हम स्कोप अपसाइट में
देखें तो स्प्लंक की हम बात करते हैं तो
ग्लोबल एंटरप्राइजेज जो होती हैं ग्लोबल
एंटरप्राइजेज जैसे कि क्लाउड नेटवर्क
आइडेंटिटी एप्लीकेशन एंड पॉइंट्स इन सब पे
ये यूज़ में आते हैं। यूज़ में लिए जाते
हैं। ग्लोबल एंटरप्राइजेस जो है उस क्लाउड
में यूज़ होते हैं। ये नेटवर्क के अंदर में
यूज़ होते हैं। आइडेंटिटी, एप्लीकेशन, एंड
पॉइंट्स इन सब जगह पे यहां पे यूज़ में लिए
जाते हैं। और ईडीआर जो है लोकलाइज़्ड एंड
पॉइंट्स पे लिए जाते हैं। ईडीआर क्या किया
जाता है? लोकलाइज़्ड एंड पॉइंट्स पे।
लोकलाइज़ एंड पॉइंट्स का मतलब यहां पे क्या
हुआ?
लोकलाइज़ एंड पॉइंट्स का मतलब क्या हुआ?
लैपटॉप्स, वर्क स्टेशंस एंड वर्चुअल मशीन
सर्वर्स। ठीक है?
जो आपके लैपटॉप्स हैं, वर्क स्टेशंस हैं,
वर्चुअल मशीन सर्वर्स हैं। यह सारी चीजें
जो है इन सब जगहों पे जो है वो यूज़ में
लिए जाते हैं। आपके ईडीआर जो है। चलिए
यहां प्राइमरी मैकेनिज्म की बात करें तो
क्रॉस लॉग डेटा को-रिलेशन एंड कॉम्प्लेक्स
इवेंट एग्रीगेशन का काम ये करता है। जो
आपका स्प्ल या एसआईएम होते हैं वो क्रॉस
लॉग डेटा कोरिलेशन डेटा को बहुत सारे डेटा
को कोरिलेट करने का काम करता है।
कॉम्प्लेक्स इवेंट्स हो रहे हैं उनको
अरेंज्ड स्ट्रक्चर वे में करने का काम
करता है। एंड इडीआर है डीप ओएस कर्नल
बिहेवियर इंस्पेक्शन एंड मेमोरी ट्रैकिंग।
इडीआर जो होती है वो कर्नल बिहेवियर का
डीप इंस्पेक्शंस करती हैं। मेमोरी
ट्रैकिंग वगैरह करती हैं। मेमोरी रिलेटेड
कोई मैलवेयर्स या अटैक्स हो रहे हैं उसके
लिए होता है। अगर हम डेटा टाइप्स की बात
करें तो स्ट्रक्चरर्ड या अनस्ट्रक्चरर्ड
लॉग्स वाया सिस लॉग्स jसon एपीआई इवेंट
चैनल इसमें आप स्ट्रक्चरर्ड अनस्ट्रक्चर
सारे लॉग्स पास होते हैं। सबके ऊपर में ये
प्रोसेसिंग होती है। एंड ईडीआर की बात
करें तो नेटिव रॉ टेलीमेट्री प्रोसेस
क्रिएशन फाइल मॉडिफिकेशन स्ट्रीम तो इसमें
जो नेटिव जो बेसिक रॉ टेलीमेट्री जो बेसिक
जो लॉग्स होते हैं जो जेरिक लॉग्स होते
हैं उसी के ऊपर ईडीआर जो है जनरली जैसे कि
प्रोसेस क्रिएशन हो गई आपकी फाइल कोई
मॉडिफिकेशन हो रही है। इस सब के ऊपर ये
अलर्ट करता है, काम करता है। तो इस दोनों
चीजों को हम जब देखेंगे अलग-अलग तरीकों से
तो आपको एग्जैक्ट आईडिया भी लग जाएगा कि
स्प्लंक या एसआईएम वो एक अलग चीज है।
ईडीआर एक अलग चीज है। तो ईडीआर को स्प्लंक
इकोस सॉरी एसआईएम इकोसिस्टम के अंदर में
इंटीग्रेट कर दिया गया। तो ईडीआर भी इसका
एक पार्ट बन चुका। तो अब ईडीआर से भी
लॉग्स आ रहे हैं। नेटवर्क से लॉग्स आ रहे
हैं। फायरव से आ रहे हैं। अलग-अलग जगह से
लॉग्स आ रहे हैं। एक जगह सब जो है वो
कलेक्ट हो रहे हैं। पास हो रहे हैं।
कोरिलेट हो रहे हैं। इंडेक्स हो रहे हैं।
नॉर्मलाइज हो रहे हैं। एंड देन एट द एंड
अलर्ट जो है थ्रो हो रहा है या इवेंट्स जो
है वो अलर्ट के थ्रू शो हो रहा है। तो ये
सारी चीजें ये पूरा प्रोसेस जो है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ये पूरा का पूरा प्रोसेस जो है ये इस
तरीके से काम करता है। ठीक है? आई होप कि
आप लोगों को समझ में आ रहा होगा। आई होप
कि आप लोगों को यह चीजें एक्सजेक्टली पता
चल गई होंगी। राइट? अब मुझे आप सब बताइए
कि आपको यहां तक अभी तक आप में से सभी से
आई एम आस्किंग आप सभी को क्या समझ में
आया? प्लीज लेट मी नो।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एवरीवन प्लीज लेट मी नो।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है प्लीज एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड ठीक है
ओके [अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
समझ में आया? ठीक है। चलिए अच्छी बात है।
बहुत बढ़िया। चलिए तो यहां पे हमारा ये जो
है फिलहाल पीपीटी सेक्शन हमारा एंड होता
है। इसको मैं यहां पे हटा देता हूं। ठीक
है? अब मैं यहां पे आपके लिए इसका ट्राई
हैक मी ओपन करता हूं। ट्राई हैक मी एंड
लेट्स गो टू ट्राईक मी। ठीक है? डायरेक्ट
मी पे चलते हैं। यहां पे मैं चलता हूं अह
इंट्रोडक्शन टु एसआईएम पे। गो टू स
इंट्रोडक्शन टू एसआईएम।
ओके। अब यहां पे एसआईएम का एक वॉक थ्रू है
आपके लिए Telegram के ऊपर में। आई डोंट नो
यह पेड पेड लैब है या फ्री है। मुझे
नहीं पता। लेट्स सी।
हां, फ्री रूम है। फ्री रूम है। इट्स अ
फ्री रूम। दैट्स ग्रेट। अच्छी बात है। आप
सबके लिए भी एक्सेसिबल है। राइट? अब हम
यहां पे आ चुके हैं। अब आप इस पे आएंगे
एसआईएम पे। तो आप यहां पे देखेंगे। देयर
आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स दैट हैज़ बीन टॉट इन दिस
पर्टिकुलर
एसआईएम प्रोसेस वॉक थ्रू। यह रूम जो है
आपके इसके अंदर में। ठीक है? यह फ्री है।
अब यहां पर लॉग्स एवरीयर लॉक्स एवरीयर आप
देखेंगे तो यह लॉक्स के बारे में बताई गई
है। अब यहां पर दो चीजें बताई गई है। देखो
उसके बारे में भी मैं डिस्कस करना चाहता
हूं क्योंकि यहां भी कुछ अच्छी इनेशन है
वो मैं आपको दिखाना चाहता हूं।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
देखो
द जो डिवाइसेस लॉक्स को जनरेट करते हैं
उनको हम लॉग सोर्सेस बोलते हैं। ठीक है?
लॉग्स जो हैं लॉक सोर्सेस उनको दो कैटेगरी
में डिवाइड किया गया है। एक होते हैं
होस्ट सेंट्रिक लॉक सोर्सेस और एक होते
हैं नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक लॉक सोर्सेस। ठीक
है? होस्ट सेंट्रिक और नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक।
सर आप मेरा रिप्लाई नहीं करते हैं।
प्रियांंशु भाई प्रियांंशु बताइए क्या
आपके क्वेश्चन है?
सर स्प्लक क्लाउड एसओसी में भी यूज़ होता
है। हां बिल्कुल देखो हो सकता है। बिल्कुल
ये टूल है। दिस इज़ अ टूल। इट कैन बी यूज़्ड
एनीवेयर। ठीक है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] किसी भी जगह पे
इंस्टॉल हो के यह यूज़ हो सकता है। होस्ट
सेंट्रिक लॉग्स है और नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक
लॉक्स है। होस्ट सेंट्रिक लॉक्स क्या होते
हैं? दी लॉग सोर्सेस कैप्चर इवेंट्स दैट
अकर्ड विद इन और रिलेटेड टू द होस्ट। यानी
होस्ट से रिलेटेड जो लॉग्स को कलेक्ट करते
हैं या कैप्चर करते हैं वो होस्ट सेंट्रिक
लॉक सोर्सेस होते हैं। ठीक है ना?
डिवाइसेस दैट जनरेट होस्ट सेंट्रिक लॉग्स
इंक्लूड Windows, लinक्स, sv etc। ये
डिवाइसेस जैसे Windows है, Linux है,
servर्स है। ये आपके होस्ट सेंट्रिक लॉक्स
को जनरेट करते हैं। एग्जांपल क्या है?
जैसे कोई यूजर एक फाइल को एक्सेस कर रहा
है। क्या? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एक
यूजर ऑथेंटिकेट करने की कोशिश कर रहा है।
एक प्रोसेस एग्जीक्यूट हो रही है या एक
प्रोसेस को ऐड या एडिट या डिलीट किया गया
है रजिस्ट्री के अंदर में। पावर शेल
एग्जीक्यूट किया गया। ये सब होस्ट
सेंट्रिक लॉक्स के एग्जांपल है। नेटवर्क
सेंट्रिक लॉक सोर्सेस क्या होते हैं?
नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक लॉक सेंसर आर जनरेटेड
व्हेन द होस्ट कम्युनिकेट विथ ईच अदर और
एक्सेस द इंटरनेट टू विजिट अ वेबसाइट।
मतलब अगर कोई दो मशीनंस आपस में बात कर
रहे हैं या बाहर इंटरनेट से कनेक्टिविटी
हो रही है उस समय जो लॉक जनरेट हो रहे हैं
वो नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक लॉक्स सोर्सेस के
अंदर हम आते हैं। जैसे कि डिवाइसेस होते
हैं फायर वाल्स हो गया, आईडीएस आईपीएससेस
हो गए, राउटर्स हो गए। ये जो लॉक जनरेट
करते हैं ये नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक लॉक्स आपके
होते हैं। जैसे कोई एसएसएच कनेक्शन बन रही
है या एक फाइल एक्सेस किया जा रहा है
एफटीपी के द्वारा वेब ट्रैफिक्स जो होते
हैं यूजर एक्सेसिंग कंपनी रिसोर्स वीpए के
थ्रू या नेटवर्क फाइल शेयरिंग एक्टिविटी
हो रही है। ये सारे नेटवर्क सेंट्रिक लॉक
सोर्सेस कहलाते हैं। ठीक है? तो ये सारी
चीजें दो तरीके के लॉक सोर्सेस होते हैं
जो आपके बताना था मुझे। इसके यहां पे
क्वेश्चंस आंसर द क्वेश्चंस वाले कॉलम्स
हैं, फेल्स हैं। आप इनको सॉल्व जरूर
कीजिएगा। मैं यहां पे आपको बताऊंगा नहीं
क्योंकि ये फ्री वाला रूम है। अगर पेड
होता तो मैं आपके लिए जरूर यह सॉल्व भी
करता और ताकि आपका भी आपको भी समझ में
वहां पे आ जाता और सॉल्व भी हो जाती
क्योंकि आप में से कई लोग के पास प्रीमियम
नहीं होता है। तो, यह फ्री है। तो, आई वुड
रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी टू प्लीज गो एंड
कंप्लीट दिस रूम। इसको जरूर कंप्लीट
कीजिएगा क्योंकि यह फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट है।
आपको बहुत कुछ जानने को मिलेगा इससे भी।
ठीक है? हालांकि मैंने सब कवर कर दिया बट
स्टिल। अब यहां पे है वाई एसआईएम। तो यहां
पे एसआईएम क्यों जरूरत होती है? तो इसका
रिक्वायरमेंट है क्योंकि क्या जरूरी है?
क्योंकि ये कलेक्ट डेटा फ्रॉम सोर्सेस।
डेटा को सोर्सेस से कलेक्ट करता है।
ठीक है? दो
सेकंड है एग्रीगेट डेटा। डेटा को एग्रीगेट
करता है। डिस्कवरी एंड डिटेक्ट थ्रेट्स।
थ्रेट्स को डिस्कवर एंड डिटेक्ट करता है
और आइडेंटिटी आइडेंटिफाई ब्रीचेस एंड
इन्वेस्टिगेट द अलर्ट्स। और ब्रचेस को
आइडेंटिफाई करके और अलर्ट्स को क्या करता
है? इन्वेस्टिगेट करता है। अब एसआईएम के
फीचर्स की हम बात करें तो यहां पे कुछ
फीचर्स दिए गए हैं। वो फीचर्स मैंने
ऑलरेडी आपको बता दिया है। जैसे
सेंट्रलाइज़्ड लॉक कलेक्शन। जैसे मैंने
पहले ही बताया कि सारे लॉक्स एक जगह पे
कलेक्ट होते हैं। ये वही चीज़ है।
नॉर्मलाइजेशन लॉस लॉक्स। मैंने पहले ही
बताया कि एक कॉमन नेमिंग स्कीम यूज़ करना
कि भैया एक ही तरह के नेमिंग यूज़ करें भाई
लॉग्स को बताने में तो नॉर्मलाइजेशन होता
है। कोरिलेशन ऑफ़ लॉग्स ऑलरेडी बताया यहां
पे कि इंडिविजुअल लॉग्स जो हैं वो काम के
नहीं होते हैं। तो एसआईएम को-रिलेट द
लॉक्स ऑफ़ डिफरेंट सोर्सेस एंड फाइंड
रिलेशनशिप इन बिटवीन देम। मतलब एसआईएम
क्या करता है? अलग-अलग लॉग सोर्सेस को एक
साथ कोरिलेट करता है एंड उनको एक दूसरे से
मैप करने की कोशिश करता है। वह एक दूसरे
के बीच में रिलेशनशिप इस्टैब्लिश करने की
कोशिश करता है कि भैया यह वाला लॉ इससे
शायद रिलेटेड है। जैसे कि हरीश लॉक्स इन
वाया वीपीए फ्रॉम एन आईपी दैट ही नेवर हैज़
प्रीवियसली यूज़्ड। हरीश एक्सेस सम
डॉक्यूमेंट्स ऑन अ शेयर ड्राइव। ही
एग्जीक्यूटेड अ पावर शेल स्क्रिप्ट। द
सिस्टम मेक्स एन आउटबाउंड नेटवर्क
कनेक्शन। अब ये सारे लॉक जो हैं अलग-अलग
लॉक्स हैं बट एक दूसरे से कहीं ना कहीं
कनेक्टेड है जो कि हरि के जो एक्टिविटी है
उसके बारे में यहां पे दिखा रहा है। तो इस
तरीके से को-रिलेशन होती है। उसके बाद
रियल टाइम अलर्टिंग। तो ये भी मैंने बताया
कि एसआईएम अपने दूसरे एक्टिव मोड में जब
आता है तो वो रियल टाइम थ्रेट डिटेक्शन
इंजन बन जाता है और वो रियल टाइम में
मलेशियस एक्टिविटीज को डिटेक्ट करना शुरू
हो जाता है। एंड देन डैशबोर्ड्स एंड
रिपोर्टिंग यानी कि जब एसआईएम का जो
डैशबोर्ड होता है वहां से सारी डैशबोर्ड्स
पे रिपोर्ट्स आती हैं। सारी मतलब सारी
इनेशन आती है और उसी के थ्रू ये सारी
रिपोर्टिंग वगैरह जो भी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
होती है जो भी चीजें देनी होती है
रिपोर्ट्स वगैरह इनेशन वगैरह वो सारी
चीजें देती है। तो ये डैशबोर्ड्स एंड
रिपोर्टिंग में आपका आता है। ठीक है? यहां
पे फिर से आंसर देने की रीड नहीं है। अब
यहां पे लॉग सोर्सेस एंड इंजेशन है। तो यह
मैंने ऑलरेडी आपको बताया है। लॉक सोर्सेस
जैसे Windows मशीन से अलग-अलग तरह के
लॉग्स आते हैं। जैसे Windows में इवेंट
लॉग्स से लॉग्स आते हैं। Linux में ये जो
पाथ्स हैं यहां से लॉग्स जनरेट होते हैं।
इसके बारे में मैंने ऑलरेडी आपको पहले ही
अगर आपको नहीं याद है
तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मैं आपको बता
देता हूं। लॉग्स के बारे में डिटेल में
मैंने ऑलरेडी जो है डिस्कस की कहां पे
डिस्कस की थी? लाइव में जाएंगे आप एसओसी
वाली क्लासेस में तो आप देखेंगे यहां पे
हमारी कौन सी थी?
हां Linux फाइल सिस्टम आर्किटेक्चर एंड
लॉग्स फॉर एसओसी। आप इसको देखेंगे तो यहां
पे आपको लॉग्स के बारे में पूरा जो है वो
आईडिया लग जाएगा। और यहां पे Windows
इवेंट लॉग्स वाली क्लासेस में Windows के
लॉग्स के बारे में आपको पता चल जाएगा। ठीक
है? तो Windows वाली ये है, Linux वाली ये
है। तो आप इसको देख के लॉक्स के बारे में
आईडिया लगा सकते हैं। उसमें मैंने ये सारी
चीजें ऑलरेडी बताई हुई हैं कि इन पाथ पे
जो है लॉग्स जनरेट होती है Linux के अंदर
में। Windows में Windows का इवेंट व्यूअर
जो होता है वहां पे आप लॉग्स देख सकते
हैं। वेब सर्वर्स की बात करें तो Linux
में मैंने यह भी बताया था कि आपको Apache
का यह पाथ है। उस पे आपको वेब सर्वर के
लॉग्स मिल जाएंगे। एंड ये सारी चीजें
मैंने आपको क्लियर करी थी।
अब लॉग इंजेशन का मतलब है ऑल दोज़ लॉग्स
प्रोवाइड अ वेल्थ ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन एंड कैन
हेल्प आइडेंटिफाई सिक्योरिटी इशूज़। लॉग्स
बहुत तरह की इनेशन प्रोवाइड करते हैं और
बहुत सारे सिक्योरिटी इशूज़ को आइडेंटिफाई
करने में हेल्प भी करते हैं। ठीक है? ये
लॉग्स का मतलब काम ही है। बेसिकली लॉग्स
का ही काम है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ईच एसआईएम
सॉल्यूशन हैज़ इट्स ओन वे ऑफ़ इंजेस्टिंग द
लॉग्स। सम कॉमन मेथड्स यूज़्ड बाय दीज़
एसआईएम सॉलशंस आर एक्सप्लेंड बिलो। अब हर
एसआईएम का ना लॉग्स को इंजेस्ट करने में
यानी लॉक्स को मतलब एक जगह वहां एक जगह पर
रखने के लिए मतलब कलेक्ट करने का एक
अलग-अलग तरीका होता है। जैसे एजेंट्स या
फॉरवर्डर का यूज़ करते हैं। फॉरवर्डर के
बारे में मैंने आपको बताया। sis लॉक्स जो
होती हैं sis लॉक्स इज़ अ वाइडली यूज़्ड
प्रोटोकॉल टू कलेक्ट डेटा फ्रॉम वेरियस
सिस्टम्स लाइक वेब सर्वर, डेटाबेस, ईटीसी।
अब sिस LX भी एक तरह का प्रोटोकॉल है
जिसके थ्रू लॉक्स को कलेक्ट किया जाता है।
फॉरवर्ड्स जो हैं या एजेंट्स होते हैं
उनको उनका भी यूज़ जैसे फॉरवर्ड मैंने
बताया आपको है। ठीक है ना? या यूनिवर्सल
फॉर ऑर्डर, हैवी फॉर ऑर्डर वह बताया था।
तो उनका भी यूज़ किया जाता है। मैनुअल
अपलोड बहुत सारे जो एसओ एसआईएम सॉलशंस हैं
वो मैनुअल अपलोड का ऑप्शन भी देते हैं।
जैसे स्प्लंक भी देता है आपका कि आप
मैनुअली लॉक्स को जो है अपलोड कर सकते हैं
फॉर एनालिसिस एंड पोर्ट फॉरवर्डिंग। पोर्ट
फॉरवर्डिंग का मतलब एक पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट पे
जो आपका टूल है ये एसआईएम टूल है वो एक
पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट पे लिसन करता रहेगा और
वहां से जो है वो सर्टेन पोर्ट पे लिसन
करेगा और वहां पे जो भी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन या
लॉक्स आ रही है वहां से वो फॉरवर्ड कर
देगा उसको आगे की तरफ इंजेस्ट करने के
लिए। ठीक है? तो इस तरीके से ये काम करती
है। बस यही चीज़ बताई गई है। उसके बाद
लास्ट में बताया गया है अलर्टिंग प्रोसेस
एंड एनालिसिस के बारे में। यह मैंने आपको
पूरा बता दिया है कि अलर्टिंग प्रोसेस
एनालिसिस किस तरीके से होता है। लाइक
काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग कि हाउ डिटेक्शन रूल
क्रिएटेड इसमें दिया हुआ है कि डिटेक्शन
रूल कैसे बनते हैं? तो ये सिंपल सा यहां
पे है कि मान लो कि देखो जैसे एक एग्जांपल
है यहां पे [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
डिटेक्शन रूल कैसे बनते हैं? जैसे मान लो
इफ अ यूजर गेट्स फाइव फेल्ड लॉगिन
एटेप्ट्स इन 10 सेकंड्स रेज़ एन अलॉट फॉर
मल्टीपल फेल्ड लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट्स। तो अगर
फाइव फाइव लॉग इन आइटम्स आ रहे हैं 10
सेकंड में तो एक ये वाला अलर्ट को थ्रो कर
दो। अब इसको बनाया कैसे? जैसे मान लो
एडवर्सरीज जो होते हैं टेंड टू रिमूव द
लॉ। एडवर्सरीज का मतलब यहां पे है जो
थ्रेट्स होते हैं या जो अटैक मतलब अटैकर्स
जो होते हैं अटैकर्स का काम होता है लॉग्स
को रिमूव करना। पोस्ट एक्सप्लॉयटेशन में
ताकि उनका ट्रैक्स क्लियर हो जाए। क्लियर
ट्रैक्स कर सके। राइट? अ यूनिक इवेंट आईडी
104 इज़ लॉक्ड एव्री टाइम अ यूजर ट्राइ्स
टू रिमूव और क्लियर लॉग्स। अब देखो अब जब
भी कोई हैकर या अटैकर या कोई भी यूजर जब
कोई अ
इवेंट लॉक्स को ही क्लियर करना चाहेगा तो
उसके लिए भी एक एक यूनिक इवेंट आईडी जनरेट
होती है। उसका नाम इवेंट आईडी होता है
104। इधर ध्यान दीजिए सभी लोग। उसका इवेंट
आईडी होता है 104। तो टू क्रिएट अ रूल
बेस्ड ऑन दिस एक्टिविटी, वी कैन सेट द
कंडीशन। वैसे रूल क्रिएट किया जा सकता है।
इफ द लॉग सोर्स इज़
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] windows
इवेंट लॉग अगर लॉग सोर्स विन इवेंट लॉग है
एंड इवेंट आईडी इज़ 104 और इवेंट आईडी 104
है। ट्रिगर एन अलर्ट इवेंट लॉग क्रिएटेड
तो एक ट्रिगर करो अलर्ट को कि इवेंट लॉग
क्रिएट हुआ है। मतलब कि इवेंट कुछ
छेड़छाड़ हुई है। लॉक्स को डिलीट किया जा
रहा है। इवेंट लॉक्स को क्लियर डिलीट किया
जा रहा है। तो ऐसे बनाया जा सकता है। इसी
तरीके से एक और सीन में यहां पे बताया गया
है। यह आप पढ़ लीजिएगा। ये इसके इसको आप
गो थ्रू एक बार कर लीजिएगा। आप गो थ्रू
एक-एक करके समझिएगा। गो थ्रू कीजिएगा।
मैंने ये सारी चीजें बता गई है। बट अगर आप
गो थ्रू करते हैं तो आपको थोड़ा मतलब ये
रूम सॉल्व करने में हेल्प हो जाएगी। ये जो
रूम है इसके सॉलशंस आप सॉल्व कर सकते हैं।
ठीक है? उसके बाद लास्ट में है लैब वर्क।
लैब वर्क भी बहुत आसान है। अब लैब वर्क
में क्या है? मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं। लैब
वर्क में क्या है?
इन द स्टैटिक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
लैब अटैच्ड अ सैंपल डैशबोर्ड एंड इवेंट्स
आर डिस्प्लेड व्हेन अ सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी
हैपेंस एंड अलर्ट इज ट्रिगरर्ड। ठीक है?
वि मींस सम इवेंट्स मैच द कंडीशन ऑफ़ सम
रूल ऑलरेडी कॉन्फ़िगर। एक ऑलरेडी रूल
कॉन्फ़िगरर्ड है। जब कोई इवेंट जब कोई
सस्पिशियस एक्टिविटी होगी, तो एक अलर्ट
आएगा। तो, हम इसको भी देखते हैं। व्यू
साइट पे चलते हैं। अब, यहां पे देखिए,
इंस्ट्रक्शंस है। हियर वी सी अ टिपिकल
एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड। क्लिक ऑन ईच विजुअलाइज़।
अब मान लो स्टार्ट एक्टिविटी करता हूं
मैं। अब यह एसआईएम का डैशबोर्ड है। कुछ इस
तरीके से। ठीक है? अब हर किसी पे भी आप
क्लिक करेंगे तो उसके बारे में डिटेल
मिलेगी। जैसे मैं इस पे क्लिक करता हूं तो
दिस विजुअलाइज़ेशन शोज़ द टॉप 10 इवेंट
आईडीज़ ऑब्ज़र्व इन द नेटवर्क। यहां पे करता
हूं। दिस शोज़ द टॉप फाइव आरडीपी कनेक्शंस
एस्टैब्लिश्ड। ये सारे डिटेल्स शो करते
हैं। अब यहीं पे हम यहां पे नीचे की तरफ
आते हैं। तो यहां पे आएगा स्टार्ट
सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी। अब मैं क्लिक करता
हूं। तो जैसे ही मैं क्लिक करूंगा थोड़ी
देर में एक सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी आ गई। देखो
ये आ गई सस्विटी। पोटेंशियल क्रिप्टो
माइनर एक्टिविटी ऑब्ज़र्व्ड। फाइंड एंड
क्लिक ऑन द ट्रिगरर्ड इवेंट टू शो द
डिटेल्स। अब क्रिप्टो माइनर एक्टिविटी एक
यहां पे आई है देखो जिसका नाम है क्यूडो
माइनर.exc तो ये आ चुका है। अब इसका पहला
क्वेश्चन है यहां पे आफ्टर क्लिकिंग द
स्टार्ट सस्पेश एक्टिविटी व्हिच प्रोसेस
कॉज़ द अलर्ट। तो क्यूडो माइनर यही अलर्ट
शो कर रहा है। तो हो गया आंसर सही। दूसरा
है फाइंड द इवेंट दैट कॉज़ द अलर्ट। फाइंड
द इवेंट दैट कॉज़ द अलर्ट। एंड आइडेंटिफाई
द यूज़र रिस्पांसिबल फॉर द प्रोसेस। अब
यूजर कौन रिस्पांसिबल है भाई? तो इस पे हम
क्लिक करते हैं। अब क्लिक करके देखते हैं।
अब यहां पे क्लिक करके देखते हैं कि भैया
ये जो क्यूडो माइनर वाला है वो कहां पे
है। देखो ये पूरी इसी तरीके से आती है। जो
आपके एसआईएम का डैशबोर्ड होता है। मैं
आपको यहां पे दिखा रहा हूं। ऐसा ही आपको
देखने को भी मिलेगा। ये याद रखिएगा।
एवरीवन प्लीज फोकस हियर। आप लोग चैट से
निकल के इधर आ जाइए।
प्लीज अ प्लीज डोंट अ
गेट इनवॉल्व्ड हियर। इसी तरीके का कुछ
एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड भी आपको देखने को मिलता
है। ठीक है?
अब इसमें आप देखो कैसे कैटेगरीज आ रही है।
इवेंट्स आईडीज आ रही है। इवेंट्स का टाइम
आता है। सीिवियरिटी आती है। न्यू
प्रोसेससेस आईडी के बारे न्यू प्रोसेस
आईडीज हैं। उसकी इनेशन है। प्रोसेस अह
प्रोसेस आईडीज़ की इनेशन है। लॉग सोर्सेस
की इनेशन है। इवेंट टाइप जो है वह बताया
गया है। सोर्स मॉड्यूल नेम बताया गया है।
होस्ट नेम बताया जा रहा है। यूजर नेम
बताया जा रहा है। प्रोसेस का नाम जो पूरा
पाथ है वह बताया जा रहा है आपको।
ऑपरेशन कोड बताया जा रहा है। सोर्स
मॉड्यूल टाइप क्या है? वह बताया जा रहा
है। सीवियरिटी की वैल्यू क्या है? इंडेक्स
के बारे में बताया जा रहा है। सब्जेक्ट
डोमेन नेम और चैनल कौन सा चैनल यूज़ हुआ वो
सारा कुछ बताया जा रहा है। तो यहां पे
हमें मतलब है क्यूडो मामाइनर से। कडो
माइनर तो इसका क्या है भैया? यहां पे यूजर
कौन है भैया? तो क्रिश है तो क्रिश हो
गया। व्हाट इज़ द होस्ट नेम ऑफ़ सस्पेक्टेड
यूजर? तो होस्ट नेम देखो। यहां पे होस्ट
नेम क्या है? एचआर2 एचआर2 हो गया।
एग्जामिन द रूल एंड स एंड द सस्पिसिस
प्रोसेस व्हिच टर्म मैच द रूल दैट कॉज़ द
अलर्ट। तो भैया अब ये अलर्ट कौन सा अब
जैसे मैं इस पे क्लिक करता हूं इस वाले
अलर्ट पे तो मैं यहां पे गुड वर्क प्रोसीड
करता हूं तो देखो यहां पे कौन सा मैच कर
रहा है वर्ड तो अलर्ट पोटेंशियल क्रिप्टो
माइनर एक्टिविटी इफ ये क्रिप्टो माइनर
एक्टिविटी करना है इफ इवेंट आईडी इक्वल टू
इतना एंड लॉग सोर्स इज़ इक्वल टू Windows
इवेंट लॉग एंड प्रोसेस नेम इज़ इक्वल टू
माइनर और क्रिप्ट तो माइनर या क्रिप्ट
वर्ड होगा तो ये अलर्ट का वो आएगा तो यहां
पे मैंने माइनर लिख दिया तो वो भी सही है
आपका अब यहां पे व्हिच ऑप्शन बेस्ट
रिप्रेजेंट्स द इवेंट? तो ऑब्वियस सी बात
है गो टू एनालिसिस एक्शन करेंगे तो ये
ट्रू पॉजिटिव है। ट्रू पॉजिटिव करेंगे।
सेव एक्शन करेंगे तो हमें एक फ्लैग मिल
जाएगा। तो हम यहां पे पहले तो ट्रू
गुड हेलो हेलो हेलो याम
ऑडिबल गाइज़ हेलो हेलो हेलो या
ऑडिबल गाइज़ ओके ठीक है। वो माइक का कुछ
इशू हो गया था। अभी आई थिंक सही है।
ठीक है। ओके दैट्स इट। तो ये हमारा आपका
लैब ये जो हमारा लैब है ये हो गया। फिर ये
बहुत आसान है। आप इसको कंप्लीट जरूर
कीजिएगा। इंट्रोडक्शन टू एसआईएम। आई
रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबडी। इट विल गेट यू सम मोर
नॉलेज एंड बाकी तो हमने सब कुछ कंप्लीट कर
लिया है। सो दैट्स ऑल फॉर द सेशन गाइस।
हमने एसआई एसआईएम के बारे में सारी चीजें
जानकारी ली। एसआईएम के बारे में जाना। आई
होप कि आप सबको समझ में आया होगा एसआईएम
के बारे में पूरी प्रोसेस हो सकता है आपको
एक बार में लाइव में ना बहुत कुछ ना समझ
में आया हो आई वुड रिक्वेस्ट कि आप वापस
से एक बार रिकॉर्डिंग देखिए और कमेंट्स तो
कर दीजिएगा रिकॉर्डिंग जब आप देखते हैं तो
कमेंट कीजिए 100 कमेंट्स कंप्लीट कीजिए
नेक्स्ट क्लासेस के लिए यह मैं बार-बार
आपको बोलता हूं सभी को बोलता हूं तो वो
काम आप कर दीजिएगा और रिकॉर्डिंग को
दोबारा जरूर देखिएगा साथ ही में जो भी
आपने सीखा जो भी आपके इंपॉर्टेंट पॉइंट्स
जो आप नोट करते हैं या जो भी आप नोट्स
बनाते हैं Lindin पे डालिए डालिए और हमें
टैग कीजिए। डिफ़्रॉनिक्स को टैग कीजिए। दिस
इज़ आल्सो वेरी वेरीेंट थिंग। ठीक है?
रिंगन पे आप जब डालते हैं, टैग करते हैं
तो हमें पता एग्जैक्टली चलता है। वो काम
कर लीजिएगा। ठीक है? चलिए अब यहां पे हम
टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट यहां पे देखते हैं। अ
हियर
लेट मी पॉप आउट। लेट मी एक्सपैंड। लेट्स
सी द टॉप फैंस लिस्ट। ये हमारी टॉप फैंस
की लिस्ट है। अगेन बहुत सारे नोन नेम्स
मुझे यहां पे दिख रहे हैं टॉप फैंस की
लिस्ट में। एंड दीज़ आर द नोन नेम्स। ओके
ग्रेट
चलिए अच्छी बात है। अ ठीक है।
ग्रेट। सो बढ़िया है। सभी लोग प्रेजेंट हैं
यहां पे। टॉप फेंस के लिस्ट में जनरली जो
होते हैं वो सारे हैं यहां पे। एंड यहां
पे अब चैट में आ जाते हैं थोड़ी सी। देख
लेते हैं यहां पे। सर लेट्स राइट डिफेंस
प्रैक्टिकल लैब और ट्रैक में सोशल मीडिया
इन एक्सपी इन एक्सपीरियंस सेक्शन। सर क्या
क्या बोल रहे हो आप? लेट्स लेट्स राइट
डिफेंस। मतलब मैं समझा ही नहीं आपके
क्वेश्चन को।
क्या क्वेश्चन है आपका?
अ
सॉरी सर। अ बट सर देयर वाज़ अ डाउट लाइक वी
आर टॉट पेंटेस्टिंग मेनली इन वि
जस्ट अपलोड द पेलोड फ्रॉम मेटा मेटाप
पॉलिटिक मेटापॉलिटिक क्या मेटास्प्लॉयड
बोल रहे हो क्या एंड पुट द आईपी एंड इट्स
डन सर व्हाट विल हैपन इट हैपेंस इन रियली
कॉर्पोरेट रियलिटी कॉर्पोरेट आल्सो हां
होता है यार होता है बिल्कुल होता है
कॉर्पोरेट में भी आप जो पेलोट बना रहे हो
उसी तरीके से अटैक्स भी होते हैं यार बट
वो वो बहुत सोफिस्टिकेटेड और बहुत ही
ज्यादा लाइक अ इनकोडेड अटैक्स होते हैं।
सोफिस्ट सोफेस्टिकेटेड अटैक्स होते हैं।
काफी सारे पेलोड्स को काफी इनकोड करके
इंक्रिप्ट करके अटैक्स परफॉर्म किए जाते
हैं। एंड ताकि डिटेक्शंस कम हो। लेस
डिटेक्टेबल बनाने की कोशिश की जा की जाती
है और कम डिटेशंस हो और ज्यादा इंपैक्ट हो
उसको यूज किया जाता है। दैट्स व्हाई वी
स्टडी एंड वी
नो अबाउट दोज़ थिंग्स राइट
ठीक है।
आई ऑलरेडी डिड दैट रूम। दैट्स ग्रेट। ओके।
गुड नाइट। गुड नाइट। गुड नाइट।
चलिए
ओके। सो आई होप कि आपको मजा आया होगा। आज
की क्लास में काफी कुछ जानने को सीखने को
मिला है। नेक्स्ट क्लास हम जल्दी लेकर आ
जाएंगे। हमारे जो गैप हुए हैं उसको कवर अप
करेंगे। ठीक है? एंड डेफिनेटली वी विल डू
दैट राइट।
नहीं यार नहीं अल्टीमेट गेमिंग नहीं।
चलिए ठीक है। ठीक है। ओके गाइस। सो फॉर
नाउ आई एम जस्ट लेविंग द सेशन एंड नेक्स्ट
क्लास में जल्दी आते हैं। मिलते हैं एंड
फिर इसको कंटिन्यू करते हैं। जल्दी हम
एसओसी की ये सीरीज भी खत्म करेंगे। आप सभी
एक प्रोफेशनल एसओसी एल1 बन जाइए। जॉब
लीजिए। जॉब गैब कीजिए। यही एक उम्मीद है।
एंड यही एक होप है। लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़
हैपनिंग। सो, लेट्स मीट इन द नेक्स्ट
क्लास गाइस। थैंक यू वेरी मच। जाते-जाते
लाइक ठोक दीजिएगा। वीडियो को शेयर कीजिएगा
उनके साथ जिनको इनकी काफी जरूरत होती है।
उस वजह से भी कई लोगों तक यह वीडियो पहुंच
जाएगी। एंड मैं आपसे मिलता हूं नेक्स्ट
क्लास में। सभी को नमस्ते। टाटा बाय-ब।